foreign
I would like to distinguish roughly
between two kinds of issues that arise
in the study of language and mind
those that appear to be within the reach
of approaches and Concepts that are
moderately well understood
what I will call problems and others
that remain as obscure to us today as
when they were originally formulated
what I will call Mysteries
the distinction reflects in part a
subjective evaluation of what has been
achieved or might be achieved in terms
of ideas now available
others see Mysteries incoherence and
confusion where to me the issues seem
rather clear and straightforward
and conversely
among the problems are these
what kinds of cognitive structures are
developed by humans on the basis of
their experience specifically in the
case of acquisition of language
what is the basis for the acquisition of
such structures and how do they develop
without prejudicing the outcome of this
investigation
we may say that humans are innately
endowed with a system of intellectual
organization
call it the initial state of the Mind
through interaction with the environment
and maturational process
the Mind passes through a sequence of
states in which cognitive structures are
represented
in the case of language it is fairly
obvious that rapid and extensive changes
take place during an early period of
life
arid a steady state is achieved which
then undergoes only minor modification
abstracting away from the latter we can
refer to this steady state as the final
state of the Mind
in which knowledge of language is
somehow represented
we can construct hypotheses concerning
the initial and final States and can
proceed to validate or reject or sharpen
these hypotheses by methods of inquiry
that are familiar
we might proceed in principle to explore
the physical realizations of the initial
and final States
and the processes involved in the
changes of state that take place
in these domains much is unknown
in this sense there are many Mysteries
here
but we have a certain grasp of the
problem
and can make progress by posing and
sometimes answering questions that arise
along the way
with at least some degree of confidence
that we know what we are doing
on the other hand
when we turn to such matters as
causation of behavior
it seems to me that no progress has been
made
that we are as much in the dark as to
how to proceed as in the past
and that some fundamental insights are
lacking
roughly where we deal with cognitive
structures either in a mature state of
knowledge and belief or in the initial
State we Face problems but not Mysteries
when we ask how humans make use of these
cognitive structures how and why they
make choices and behave as they do
although there is much that we can say
as human beings with intuition and
insight there is little I believe that
we can say as scientists
what I have called elsewhere the
creative aspect of language use
remains as much a mystery to us as it
was to the cartesians who discussed it
in part in the context of the problem of
other Minds
some would reject this evaluation of the
state of our understanding I do not
propose to argue the point here but
rather to turn to the problems that do
seem to be amenable to inquiry
imagine a scientist henceforth s who is
unencumbered by the ideological baggage
that forms part of our intellectual
tradition and is thus prepared to study
humans as organisms in the natural world
let us consider a course of inquiry that
s might undertake sketching conclusions
that he might tentatively reach along
the way and then confront s with some of
the questions of methodology and
principle that have been raised by a
number of philosophers who have
discussed the nature and goals of
linguistic Theory
s might begin with the observation that
people seem to act in systematic ways
with respect to the objects around them
and that they use and respond to
expressions in organized ways
he might also conclude that humans
rather early in their lives seem to
arrive at steady states of development
in these respects states which are then
modified only in detail and which
provide a basis for human actions and
responses
investigation of these matters requires
idealization and abstraction but s
should not be put off by this familiar
contingency of rational inquiry
s might now proceed to characterize
these steady States
attributing to the organism to cognitive
structures
1. a system of beliefs and expectations
about the nature and behavior of objects
and two a system of language
suppose he calls the first system common
sense and the second grammar s might
then proceed to try to account for what
people do perhaps an experimentally
contrived situations on the basis of
these two postulated structures and
further assumptions about information
processing capacities
s might study for example the ability of
his subjects to recognize and identify
complex physical objects and predict
their behavior under various
circumstances
he might find that there are qualitative
differences in their ability to
recognize human faces and other objects
of comparable complexity
this investigation might lead us to
attribute to his subjects as an element
of their common sense an abstract theory
of possible faces and the system of
projection which abstracting away from
the effects of memory restrictions and
the like
enables the subject to predict how a
face will appear under a range of
empirical conditions given a few
presentations
s might also discover that his subjects
react quite differently to the
Expressions 1 through 4. 1. John's
friends appeared to their wives to hate
one another
2. John's friends appeared to marry to
hate one another
3. John's friends appealed to their
wives to hate one another
four John's friends appealed to Mary to
hate one another
to verify one and two
the subjects might inquire whether the
wives respectively marry think that each
friend hates the other friends
asked to verify three they might seek to
determine whether each friend directed
his wife to hate the other wives
the subjects would assign for an
entirely different status
though if pressed they could impose an
interpretation
presumably that each friend appealed to
Mary to hate the other friends
in the case of one through three the
problem of imposing an interpretation in
this sense does not arise
s might contrive various experimental
techniques to sharpen and clarify these
results and with luck and diligence he
might arrive at a plausible Theory
namely the grammar attained by his
subjects as part of their final State
incorporates a system of rules that
characterize one through three but not
four
as well-formed
that assigns John's friends as the
subject of hate in one and two but not
three
rather their wives is the subject of
hate in this case
that assigns a one-to-one correspondence
to John's friends and their wives in
three and so on
s's conclusions about these matters
would be stated in a theoretical
language that he would devise including
such Notions as well-formed subject and
others
and again it would be necessary to
construct various idealizations
he would discover that when Expressions
become too complex in specific ways
for example with too much self-embedding
an abstract property of structures that
s might discover if he proceeded
properly
subjects respond in ways that are not
predictable in terms of grammar alone
though given time and computation space
under contrived experimental conditions
the responses Converge on those
predicted in terms of the grammar
on the basis of such discoveries
s would be led to distinguish between
the grammar and a system of information
processing perhaps not specific to
language
and to account for actual Behavior in
terms of the interaction of these
systems
similarly s might discover that grammar
interacts with other systems of
knowledge and belief to determine how
sentences are interpreted
thus he might conclude that the
one-to-one correspondence assigned to
Jon's friends and the wives in three is
in part a matter of grammar and in part
a result of factual knowledge
suppose their wives is replaced by their
children in three
then interpretations multiply
one is that each friend appealed to his
children to hate one another but not to
hate the children of other friends
there is still a one-to-one correlation
between John's friends and a set of sets
of children
but not between the friends and the
union of these sets
the one-to-one correlation between
friends and wives derives in part from
factual assumptions about monogamy which
also eliminate interpretations of one
another of the sort that are possible
indeed I believe favored
when their wives is replaced by their
children
proceeding in this way s might develop a
general theory of cognitive structures
in which grammar appears as a specific
component
while s would remain properly cautious
about such conclusions he would not if
rational shy away from them on grounds
of their complexity and abstractness
examples such as one through four would
reveal to us that such Notions as
analogy and generalization do not carry
him very far in understanding human
cognitive capacities
at least in the domain of language
thus although one and three are very
similar they differ only in one
phonological feature hence minimally
nevertheless speakers of the language
understand them in very different ways
ignoring the obvious analogies
similarly four can be interpreted on the
analogy of one two or three and subjects
if pressed might well impose such an
interpretation
nevertheless the status of four is
entirely different from that of its
analogs and the obvious generalizations
are not employed by s's subjects to
incorporate four within their
grammatical system
these are typical examples that would
lead us to reject the idea that an
account of language can be based on
Notions of analogy and generalization as
these have often been employed in the
intellectual tradition of his subjects
noting further the Persistence of the
contrary belief in the face of
disconfirming evidence that is quite
easy to come by
s might try to discover ideological or
social factors that lead his subjects to
reject theories that seem to offer some
hope of success
while clinging to beliefs that appear to
be inconsistent with even the most
Elementary observations
putting the sociological investigation
to the side
s might continue to investigate the
hypothesis that the final state of his
subjects incorporates a generative
grammar embedded among and interacting
with other cognitive structures
he might take the grammar to be a system
of rules and principles
that assigns to each of an infinite set
of Expressions a semantic phonetic and
syntactic representation
each of these being a representation in
some Universal system
there are of course alternative
hypotheses to be considered in other
words s is engaged in empirical science
given the suggested approach various
qualifications are possible and many
questions arise about the nature of
these rules and representations
these are the questions that s would
pursue in attempting to refine and
elaborate his theory of the final state
thus s's analyzes would proceed at two
levels of abstraction
he would be concerned with relations
between particular stimuli and
particular percepts
the relation for example between one and
an abstract characterization of it
that serves as a basis for s's
explanation of how his subjects deal
with it
s's analysis would proceed to a still
higher level of abstraction
at which he would consider the general
system of rules grammar that determines
these particular relationships
this grammar is an explanatory Theory
going far beyond the evidence at hand
and easily falsifiable by new
investigations
s might conclude that his subjects
attribute knowledge of a language to
their fellows when he s is attributing a
corresponding grammar to these subjects
as part of their final State again under
appropriate idealizations
pursuing his efforts to map out the
cognitive structures of his subjects s
might conclude that each of them
possesses an unconscious theory of
humans in accordance with which they
attribute knowledge of language to other
humans
s might also proceed to investigate the
physical representation of grammars
theories of humans Common Sense
information processing systems other
systems of factual knowledge and belief
and other cognitive structures that
appear to be components of the attained
steady States
in this way he would develop a science
of human cognitive structures and
perhaps their physical basis his inquiry
might take various turns and face
innumerable problems but again
there seems no reason to expect that in
this domain he would run up against
impenetrable Mysteries
suppose that among the people that s is
investigating some happen to be
physicists
observing their behavior in prediction
inquiry Exposition and so forth
s might attribute to these individuals
still another cognitive structure call
it knowledge of physics
s would now be postulating inter Alia
three cognitive systems each somehow
represented in the human mind grammar
common sense and knowledge of physics
he might notice that there are striking
differences between these systems
knowledge of physics is conscious
knowledge the physicist can expound and
articulate it and convey it to others in
contrast the other two systems are quite
unconscious for the most part and Beyond
the bounds of introspective report
furthermore knowledge of physics is
qualitatively distinct from the other
two cognitive structures in the manner
of its acquisition and development
grammar and Common Sense are acquired by
virtually everyone
effortlessly rapidly in a uniform manner
merely by living in a community under
minimal conditions of interaction
exposure and care
there need be no explicit teaching or
training and when the latter does take
place it has only marginal effects on
the final State achieved
to a very good first approximation
individuals are indistinguishable
apart from gross deficits and
abnormalities
in their ability to acquire grammar and
Common Sense
individuals of a given Community each
acquire a cognitive structure that is
Rich and comprehensive and essentially
the same as the systems acquired by
others knowledge of physics on the other
hand is acquired selectively and often
painfully through generations of Labor
and careful experiment with the
intervention of individual genius and
generally through careful instruction
it is not quickly and uniformly attained
as a steady state
but is transmitted and modified
continually on the basis of controlled
inquiry and an explicit record that
provides the basis for the next stage of
construction
having discovered this much
s should realize that humans are somehow
specifically adapted to acquire grammar
and common sense as they are adapted to
walk and not to fly
proceeding to a still higher level of
abstraction in his inquiries s would
attempt to characterize this specific
adaptation
thus returning to the postulated theory
of faces he might ask how this Theory
with a characterization of possible
faces and a system of projection arises
in the organism
why is it specifically that there is no
comparable Theory as part of common
sense for certain other objects of
comparable complexity what assumptions
about the initial state of the organism
and its biologically determined
maturational processes
might account for the construction of
this aspect of Common Sense within
empirically given conditions of time and
access to data
investigation of this problem might lead
us to the hypothesis that basic elements
of the theory of human faces are
represented in the initial state
as a biologically determined innate
property
knowing something about the evolution of
organisms s would not regard this as a
strange or unexpected conclusion
notice incidentally that biologically
determined systems might begin to
function only at a particular level of
maturation or after appropriate
triggering experience
thus the theory of faces like language
might be innate though fully functional
only at a particular stage of
development
to test these hypotheses and other
related ones
s might try to vary conditions of
exposure and to study the variety of
systems of common sense that result
to the extent that there is concomitant
and systematic variation
s would adjust his postulates concerning
innate structure
in this way he would develop a theory of
learning of common sense in the only
rational way
namely by characterizing as closely as
possible the states achieved by the
organism steady states in the case of
Common Sense and then specifying a
function that assigns the attained
steady state as a value given a
characterization of the data available
the resulting theory of learning of
Common Sense might involve complex
assumptions as to the interaction of
maturation and experience
with regular succession of states of
determinate kinds in the sense say of
piagetian theory
whatever the complexity of the problem
it seems to pose no special Mysteries
and we can see how it would be
investigated
there are various approaches that s
might explore in attempting to construct
a theory of learning of Common Sense
to mention two
he might postulate a schematism innate
to the mind
that is refined and further articulated
by experience
thus he might conclude that the visual
system contains analyzing mechanisms
that interprets sensory presentations in
terms of line
angle and motion
and that these mechanisms are simply put
into operation on exposure to
appropriate experience so that as
Descartes and cudworth proposed we see a
presented figure as a perhaps distorted
regular geometrical figure because of
the mind's initial adaptation to produce
such figures as exemplars for the
interpretation of experience
similar ideas might be developed to
explain recognition of faces and much
else
alternatively s might suppose that the
mind is a blank tablet equipped only
with the ability to record Impressions
and retain faded Impressions to
construct associations among presented
Impressions to match impressions
perhaps along certain innately given
dimensions
to generalize along Dimensions that are
innate or constructed
to modify the probability of response in
terms of contingencies of reinforcement
defined in terms of the stimulus space
and so on
let us call these two quite different
approaches R and E respectively
I mean to suggest by this terminology
that they reflect leading ideas of
rationalism and empiricism
I have discussed the historical question
elsewhere
and we'll return to it below
for the moment I will only restate my
belief that these formulations as
presented were quite appropriate
and that they offer an Illuminating
framework for the investigation of
problems of learning
as just noted s is not bound to a strict
version of r or e
but might develop a more complex
approach
with successive stages based on the
interplay of maturation and experience
and so on
in the case of grammar similar remarks
apply
s would discover that there is
considerable Variety in attained
grammars but that individuals are not
specifically adapted to acquiring one or
another of these systems rather they
will with essentially equal facility
acquire knowledge of the language of the
community in which they live given
minimal conditions of exposure and care
investigating this problem
s might make another quite appropriate
idealization to a hypothetical uniform
and homogeneous speech community
now abstracting away from The observed
variety within given societies
he would try to discover the property of
the Mind P that enables a child endowed
with P to acquire the grammar of the
language spoken under this idealization
as in the case of any empirical
hypothesis the legitimacy of the
idealization might be challenged but in
this case
s would do well to proceed with the
idealization
attempting to explain the complex
real-life situation in terms of p and
other human capacities
s would not thereby be ignoring the
Intriguing problems of variation of
dialect and individual Style
as sometimes alleged
rather he would be approaching these
questions in terms of a specific Theory
devised for the idealization
if indeed there is such a property p
and if as seems likely it is a
fundamental factor in acquisition of
language in the complex situations of
real life
then s would now be in a position to
undertake a serious investigation of the
more complex problems with some hope of
success
having gotten this far s would now
proceed to investigate the property p
again he might proceed in the manner of
r formulating a general schematism
call it Universal grammar and an
evaluation procedure which he would
postulate jointly constitute P or an
essential element in it endowed with
these systems in its initial State the
child develops a grammar by employing
the evaluation procedure to select among
grammars that conform to Universal
grammar
if the latter is sufficiently
restrictive a small amount of evidence
might lead quickly to the selection of a
grammar that is very rich and complex
and that goes well beyond this evidence
in particular a grammar that provides
representations for sentences that are
not related by any useful notion of
analogy or generalization to the
evidence available
another approach along the lines of e
would be to formulate certain analytic
procedures again attributed to the
organism as an innate property which can
be applied to the data of sense to
produce a grammar if we interpret the
methods of structural Linguistics based
on segmentation and classification as a
learning theory
contrary to the intentions of those who
develop these methods so far as I know
then it would be reasonable to regard
these as an instance of e perhaps the
most complex version that has yet been
developed
adopting an approach of the character of
r or e or some combination of the two
s would now be trying to develop a
theory of language learning again in the
only rational way
namely he would first characterize as
closely as he could the states achieved
and then having made certain assumptions
about what is learned he would attempt
to specify a function that assigns
appropriate constituents of the achieved
final State as a value given the
characterization of the data available
to the learner
this function would constitute his
theory of language learning
to make the discussion a bit more
concrete
consider again examples one through four
let us suppose that s has moved from the
study of the relation between particular
stimuli and particular percepts to a
study of the grammar that determines an
infinite class of such relations by
assigning a structural description to
each expression
in particular a representation in terms
of phonetic semantic and syntactic
properties
in the case of one through four
let us say that the grammar he
postulates is a familiar
transformational grammar
of the sort described in chapter 3.
which derives the surface structures of
one through four
from the initial phrase markers deep
structures
One Prime through four Prime
respectively omitting details
One Prime
Open Bracket sub s Open Bracket sub n p
x closed bracket Open Bracket sub VP
appeared Open Bracket to their wives
closed bracket Open Bracket sub s Open
Bracket sub NP
John's friends closed bracket Open
Bracket sub VP to hate one another
quadruple closed brackets
two prime same as One Prime with Mary in
place of their wives
3 Prime Open Bracket sub s Open Bracket
sub NP John's friends closed bracket
Open Bracket sub VP appealed Open
Bracket to their wives closed bracket
Open Bracket sub s Open Bracket sub npx
closed bracket Open Bracket sub VP to
hate one another
quadruple close brackets
four Prime same as three Prime with Mary
in place of their wives
we may take X to be an initial phrase
marker variable an abstract ProForm
which is either replaced in a derivation
or placed by an interpretive rule within
the scope of a controlling NP
1. respectively two is derived from One
Prime respectively two prime by the rule
of NP pre-posing which replaces The
Matrix subject X by the embedded n p
John's friends
we might think of this operation as
leaving a trace T interpreted by
Convention as controlled by the NP that
has been moved from this position
in the case of three
an interpretive rule assigns x to the
control of the NP their wives
the mode of application of this rule
is a property of the verb appeal
compare five where they refers to the
wives and six where it refers to John's
friends
5.
John's friends made an appeal to their
wives that they should hate one another
6. John's friends made a promise to
their wives that they would hate one
another
suppose we now assume that thematic
relations such as agent instrument and
so on are assigned in a general way in
terms of relations expressed in initial
phrase markers and lexical properties
and that other aspects of semantic
representation scope anaphora Etc are
determined by surface structure
suppose we also have a reciprocal rule
that gives the meaning of structures of
the form blank NP blank one another
blank
when the two phrases in question are
anaphorically related
this rule is not without its
complications
thus compare John's parents hate one
another
John's grandparents hate one another in
the case of 3 and 4 the anaphoric
relation cannot hold between John's
friends and one another
though it can hold between their wives
and one another and between Mary and one
another
in the latter case the reciprocal rule
gives gibberish accounting for the
status of four
the condition that determines how this
anaphoric relation May apply is of
considerable generality
one might propose various formulations
I will call it the specified subject
condition
henceforth
SSC
and formulate it as follows
7.
in a structure of the form Z is the
subject of w y v and is contained by a
condition that also contains position X
no rule can relate X and Y if Z is the
subject of w y v and is not controlled
by X
for discussion of the condition and
related matters see chapter 3.
this condition prevents an anaphoric
relation from holding in The Unwanted
cases discussed above
it also applies in many other cases
consider the following
eight
Mary appeared to John's friends to hate
one another
9 a
John's friends appeared to me to hate us
9B
John's friends appealed to me to kill us
9C I appeared to John's friends to hate
us
9d
I appealed to John's friends to kill us
10 a
John's friends saw pictures of one
another themselves
10B
John's friends saw Mary's pictures of
one another themselves
11 a
who did you see pictures of 11b
who did you see Mary's pictures of
12a
I didn't see pictures of many of the
children
12b I didn't see John's pictures of many
of the children
13 a
Latin is a waste of time for us to study
13B Latin is a waste of time for us for
them to teach us
13c
it is a waste of time for us to study
Latin
13d
it is a waste of time for us
for them to teach us Latin
eight has no interpretation
John's friends cannot be related
anaphorically to one another because of
SSC
since the trace left by NP proposing is
controlled by Mary and the reciprocal
rule cannot assign an interpretation to
the pair marry one another
9A and 9d are fully grammatical
but 9B and 9C have the same Oddity as do
I hate us and I'll kill us
a rule called by postal the unlike
person constraint
up requires that a pair NP pronoun have
disjoint reference
up does not apply in cases 9A and 9d
being blocked by SSC if we replace Us by
them in 9A through D grammaticality is
reversed throughout for the same reasons
if them is interpreted as anaphoric
in the case of 10B but not 10A
SSC blocks the reciprocal and reflexive
rule under an appropriate definition of
subject
thus 10A is grammatical but not 10B
the same is true of 11a and B
12a may be interpreted as meaning that I
saw pictures a few that is not many of
the children but 12b cannot be
interpreted analogously as meaning that
I saw John's pictures a few not many of
the children
the reason is that SSC blocks the rule
assigning the meaning few to not blank
many
thus if 12b is interpretable at all it
can only be understood as meaning that
John's pictures of many of the children
are such that I didn't see them
13 a is a paraphrase of 13c
but 13B is not well formed and in
particular is not a paraphrase of the
well-formed 13d
again
SSC explains the difference
if we take the abstract phrase structure
to be as indicated by the pause in 13
conclusion for which there is
independent evidence thus once again
analogies are blocked by the general
condition SSC
it is worth emphasizing that each of
these examples adds further support to
the conclusion that approaches of the
character of e which assigns a
fundamental role to segmentation
classification analogy and
generalization are mistaken in principle
furthermore in these examples at least
semantic explanations seem beside the
point
thus there is no semantic consideration
that blocks the interpretation 13d 413b
or that prevents eight from having the
perfectly sensible interpretation it
appears to each of John's friends
that Mary hates the other or others just
as two has the interpretation it
appeared to Mary that each of John's
friends hates the other or others
in such cases we might trivialize the
notion analogy by building into it some
condition equivalent to SSC
but this is clearly beside the point
notice that SSC itself might well have a
functional or semantic explanation
but this is a different matter
such examples might lead our scientist s
to postulate a grammar containing such
rules as NP proposing reciprocal
interpretation up a rule giving the
meaning of not blank many and so on the
rules would be governed by such
principles as SSC and by the general
principles of interpretation of initial
phrase markers and surface structure
mentioned earlier
see chapter 3
if s is inclined to believe that the
theory of language learning is of the
character of e he will attempt to design
procedures of Association habit
formation induction or analysis by
segmentation and classification that
will give this grammar as output on the
basis of a record of data a system of
procedures will be tested for adequacy
in terms of its success in this task
as just noted an analysis of properties
of the grammar suggests that no such
approach is feasible and that a theory
of the character of R is much more
likely to be successful
following this line of thinking s might
ask what elements of the grammar might
be candidates for Universal grammar the
schematism that constitutes an element
of the initial State the property p
the empirical conditions of his problem
are plain enough
the variety of languages provides an
upper bound on the richness and
specificity of the properties that he
may assign to Universal grammar the
necessity of accounting for acquisition
of particular grammars provides a lower
bound
between these bounds lies the theory of
language learning what we have called LT
for H in L in chapter 1.
s might propose for example that SSC
some of the principles of interpretation
of initial phrase markers and surface
structures
the conditions on permissible
grammatical rules and so on are elements
of universal grammar
whereas such rules as NP proposing are
specific to English or have property
specific to English
thus he might conclude that a child must
learn the rule of NP proposing or some
of its properties
but need not learn SSC or the general
properties of grammar
rather he would have this information
available as an element of P
a property of his initial State though
as noted earlier this genetically
determined property may as in other
familiar cases function only at a
certain maturational stage or under
appropriate triggering conditions
the child will thus select the grammar
meeting these conditions and containing
the rule of NP proposing with its
particular properties
evidence for the latter rule is
considerable
since there has been much confusion
about these matters
perhaps it may be useful to recall a
still simpler case that illustrates the
general point
consider again the discussion of the
principle of structure dependence of
rules discussed in chapter 1. for
reasons explained there s would
naturally conclude that some feature of
the child's initial State leads him to
reject the structure-independent
hypothesis 1 to account for question
formation selecting instead the more
abstract and complex structure-dependent
hypothesis 2. on the basis of evidence
compatible with both
s might conclude that Universal grammar
provides a notation for rules that
simply does not permit the formulation
of structure independent rules
despite the advantages that they would
have for some different organism or
device
this conclusion would constitute one
part of s's theory of language learning
the example again supports the more
General conclusion that a theory of
language learning is of the character of
R rather than e
if we sufficiently enrich the system of
universal grammar postulated as an
element of the innate property p
it may be possible to account for
acquisition of grammar on the basis of
The Limited evidence available
at least this seems a feasible Prospect
succeeds in developing a tentative
theory of learning for common sense and
for language
if my guess is right these would be of
the character of r
that is they would involve fixed and
highly restrictive schemata which come
into operation under limited conditions
of exposure to data determine the
interpretation of these data as
experience and lead to the selection of
systems of rules
grammar common sense
which are put to use in human action and
interaction
it is not excluded that the schematisms
for grammar and for common sense have
non-trivial common elements an S will
naturally search for these
there may be generalized learning
strategies that form part of both of
these empirical theories
on the other hand it seems likely that
these schematisms will have unique
elements as well
just as common sense May well have
special devices to distinguish faces
from other geometrical objects
there is no reason to expect it to find
in the property P significant analogs to
the analyzing mechanisms for
identification of faces or determination
of line angle and motion
there is no reason to expect that the
principle of structure dependence or SSC
will appear in the theory of Common
Sense
that some sufficiently abstract level
one may find analogies
s might ask whether the system for
identifying faces involves an abstract
representation or model and a
transformational system of projection
but
as a scientist s would have no dogmatic
beliefs as to the character of the
various systems of learning and their
interrelation
rather
this would be an empirical problem that
he would hope to solve to the extent
that succeeds in characterizing the
innate properties of mind that make
possible the learning of grammar and
Common Sense
he would be able to explain why these
systems are qualitatively so different
from the third cognitive structure
mentioned earlier knowledge of physics
that is he would now regard the
properties of mind that underlie the
acquisition of language and common sense
as biological properties of the organism
On a par in this respect with those that
enable a bird to build a nest or
reproduce a characteristic song
or for that matter comparable to the
properties that account for the
development of particular organs of the
body
see chapter one
humans are not specially adapted in the
same way to the learning of physics
parenthetically s might conclude that
something similar is true of physics as
well
the human mind is a biologically given
system with certain powers and limits
as Charles sanders-pierce argued man's
mind has a natural adaptation to
imagining correct theories of some kinds
if man had not the gift of a mind
adapted to his requirements he could not
have acquired any knowledge
the fact that admissible hypotheses
are available to this specific
biological system accounts for its
ability to construct rich and complex
explanatory theories
but the same properties of mind that
provide admissible hypotheses May well
exclude other successful theories as
unintelligible to humans
some theories might simply not be among
the admissible hypotheses determined by
the specific properties of mind that
adapt us to imagining correct theories
of some kinds
though these theories might be
accessible to a differently organized
intelligence
or these theories might be so remote in
an accessibility ordering of admissible
hypotheses that they cannot be
constructed under actual empirical
conditions though for a differently
structured mind they might be easily
accessible
if s regards humans as part of the
natural world such speculations will
seem by no means strange or
incomprehensible to him
and he might in fact attempt to
investigate them and establish specific
conclusions about these matters through
scientific inquiry
in pursuing this effort
he would note that while man's mind is
no doubt adapted to his requirements
there is no reason to suppose that
discovery of scientific theories in
particular domains is among the
requirements met through natural
selection
s might go on to develop a theory of
problems and Mysteries for the human
organism
there would be problems in domains where
admissible or readily accessible
hypotheses are close to correct and
Mysteries elsewhere
for this organism
to take a specific case
consider the question of causation of
behavior discussed briefly in chapter
one
it might be that our inability to deal
with this question reflects a temporary
condition of ignorance
a defect that can be overcome in
Principle as science progresses
but s might discover that this
optimistic view is incorrect
and that the human mind is inherently
incapable of developing scientific
understanding of the processes by which
it itself functions in certain domains
Kant suggested that the schematism of
our understanding in its application to
appearances in their mere form
is an art concealed in the depths of the
human soul
whose real modes of activity nature is
hardly likely to ever allow us to
discover
and to have open to our gaze
perhaps this is true in some respects at
least
there is nothing contradictory in the
belief that investigation of the
inherent intellectual capacities of a
specific biological organism
humans
might lead s
even if s is human himself to a
scientific demonstration that some
possible Sciences lie Beyond human grasp
perhaps the science of causation of
behavior among them
I am not urging this conclusion but
merely noting that it is not ruled out a
Priory
returning to the more comfortable matter
of problems that do not seem to be
Mysteries
let us suppose that s has now
established the basis for the
fundamental distinction between grammar
and Common Sense on the one hand and
knowledge of physics on the other
though the latter two is derived on the
basis of specific properties of mind
it does not reflect these properties in
the same way as language and common
sense to
hence the vast qualitative difference in
relative accessibility
s could not I believe determine that
common sense and grammar are
qualitatively different in this respect
from physics merely by inspecting the
three cognitive structures that he has
been led to attribute to humans within
his comprehensive theory of their
attained intellectual organization
if our present beliefs are near correct
the grammar of language is a highly
intricate system of rules and principles
there is no absolute sense of the notion
Simplicity in terms of which grammar is
simpler than say Atomic physics
and although Common Sense has not been
investigated in a comparable way
much the same May well be true in this
case
the qualitative differences that s would
discover in his investigation of humans
doubtless reflect the structure of the
Mind as a contingent biological system
this is the only rational conclusion I
believe
this Persian view of acquisition of
cognitive structures
should not be strange to physiological
psychologists at least see chapter one
it might be suggested that much of
learning theory has been investigating
an artifact unnatural learning under
experimental conditions devised so as to
be outside the organism's inherent
capacities
conditions which thus provide smooth
learning curves and the like but perhaps
tell us very little about the organism
studied
when a learning theory is formulated
with sufficient precision
it becomes possible to ask whether it is
capable in principle of accounting for
the attainment of a state of
intellectual organization or a cognitive
structure that we have reason to
postulate for the mature organism
suppose for example that a specific
learning theory can be demonstrated to
have the following property
an otherwise unstructured system that
can be modified in accordance with the
mechanisms of this Theory can approach
in the limit
any finite State device that produces
strings left to right as it shifts from
state to state but nothing other than
such a device
since it is well known that even the
syntax of extremely simple systems
for example propositional calculus
cannot be represented by such a device
and that the syntax of language surely
cannot
we can conclude it once that the
learning theory is inadequate as a
theory of language learning
thus a theory which predicts convergence
towards demonstrably inadequate systems
must obviously be rejected as a theory
of the actual attainment of systems that
are far richer
in this case then
s could go beyond the conclusion that
General learning theories of known sorts
are completely implausible
in fact the scientist s
if indeed unencumbered by our
intellectual tradition would I think be
unlikely ever to have considered the
notion that there is a theory of
learning in any interesting sense
thus suppose that there is a general
theory of learning that applies to rats
as well as humans and that humans differ
from rats simply in that they make use
of its mechanisms more rapidly fully and
effectively
and can thus attain more complex states
by means of the devices postulated in
this Theory
we would then conclude that humans must
be as far superior to rats in May's
running ability as they are inability to
acquire language
but this is grossly false
similar observations would lead a
rational scientist to conclude at once
that the human ability to learn language
involves a special faculty or cognitive
system of some sort
distinct from the cognitive system that
underlies the ability to learn how to
run a maze and unavailable to rats or
as far as We Know
any other organism
for if language were simply acquired by
a generalized learning strategy that
applies as well in other domains say
maze running
we would expect other organisms that are
comparable to humans in these other
domains
and thus by assumption use strategies
similar to those employed by humans in
these domains to have comparable
language acquisition ability as well
the properties of common sense that are
involved in the special human ability if
such exists to deal with faces as
compared with other geometrical figures
the properties of universal grammar the
properties that distinguish grammar and
Common Sense from knowledge of physics
would also lead s to reject the
hypothesis that there is a general
learning theory common to all organisms
undifferentiated in a single organism
with respect to cognitive domain
these observations would lead us to the
Natural conclusion that the intellectual
organization of a mature human is a
complex integrated system that includes
cognitive structures that are acquired
on the basis of rather specific initial
adaptations
the non-trivial content of the theory of
learning would be given by specifying
these initial adaptations
and the ways in which they change
through maturation and experience
the steady states that are attained
uniformly and rapidly should give
particular insight into the nature of
the organism
these steady States might well reflect
quite different physiological properties
and structures there is little reason to
suppose that there are laws of learning
of any substance and generality that
account for the acquisition of these
complex and specific steady States
or for the integration of cognitive
structures that constitute the mature
mind
problems of acquisition of knowledge and
belief have generally been investigated
in a way that to a natural scientist
might seem rather perverse
there has been little attention to the
problem of characterizing what is
learned rather certain apriori
assumptions have been presented as to
how learning takes place
principles of Association habit
formation and the like
these are priori assumptions have been
pursued with speculative and
experimental studies of the systems that
might be acquired by these methods with
virtually no effort to establish that
the systems that can be acquired are
those that are acquired
a more natural approach it seems to me
is the one sketched above
analysis of the states attained followed
by attempts to determine the nature of
systems capable of attaining these
states under given conditions of time
and access to data
and investigation of the physical basis
for these achievements whatever it may
be
psychologists sometimes go so far as to
Define their discipline so as to exclude
consideration of the states attained
thus it is common to distinguish
linguistics
taken as the study of grammar from
psychology which is concerned with
behavior and learning
to a scientist following the course
outlined for s
this would seem a senseless distinction
Linguistics is simply that part of
psychology that is concerned with one
specific class of steady States
the cognitive structures that are
employed in speaking and understanding
the study of language learning is
concerned with the acquisition of such
cognitive structures
and the study of behavior is concerned
with the ways in which they are put to
use
it is self-defeating to construct a
discipline that is concerned with use
and attainment of some cognitive
structure
but that excludes consideration of the
structure itself
equally misleading I think
is the tendency in philosophical
discussion to speculate on the ways in
which language and its use might be
taught
language is not really taught for the
most part
rather it is learned
by mere exposure to the data
no one has been taught the principle of
structure dependence of rules or SSC or
language specific properties of such
rules as NP proposing
nor is there any reason to suppose that
people are taught the meaning of words
it may be true that teaching someone how
to use an expression is the native soil
from which talk about meaning has grown
but this historical comment gives little
reason to suppose that explanations of
meaning are exhausted or even Advanced
by an account of teaching
the study of how a system is learned
cannot be identified with the study of
how it is taught
nor can we assume that what is learned
has been taught
to consider an analogy that is perhaps
not too remote
consider what happens when I turn on the
ignition in my automobile
a change of state takes place
we might investigate the characteristics
of the new state by examining fumes from
the exhaust the vibration level
the motion of the car when I press the
accelerator and so on
a careful study of the interaction
between me and the car that led to the
attainment of this new state would not
be very Illuminating
similarly certain interactions between
me and my child result in his learning
hence knowing English
we can learn something about this new
state in ways outlined earlier
but a careful study of the interactions
between me and my child that result in
his attaining this new state
might give little insight into what it
is that he has learned
or what kind of an organism he is
no doubt John Austin is correct in
saying that when we are asked what is
the meaning of the word rat we can reply
in words or get the questioner to
imagine an experience or situation in
which the word would or would not be
used
but from this observation we cannot go
on to conclude as he does
that this description tells us all that
we might reasonably want to know about
the meaning of the word
it seems that he is relying on the
implicit assumption that when we have
described how we might teach
we need no longer ask what is learned
Austin is thus limiting himself to a
description of turning on the ignition
whereas the model of language that he is
condemning in these remarks is concerned
rather to give an account of the state
of the system that is activated by these
manipulations
let us ask finally how s might go about
describing the results of his inquiries
specifically consider the much debated
question whether the cognitive
structures S is attributing to the
organism constitute some kind of belief
or knowledge
consider first the case of Common Sense
S is attributing to his subject a system
of rules and principles concerning the
organization and behavior of objects
s claims that his subject differs from a
rock or a bird in that this cognitive
structure is an element of his final
state
since the subject is a physical organism
the system attributed to him must have a
finite representation
evidently there are many conceivable
finite representations of the system
however much we know about it
but s will not therefore conclude that
there is no way to choose among these on
empirical grounds
the empirical evidence is never
exhausted
furthermore
discoveries now unanticipated may reveal
the relevance of certain types of
evidence
that seem now to have no bearing on the
issue
s might arrive at a general principle of
organization
that excludes some finite
representations but not others
and he might show that acquisition of
cognitive structures in this and other
cases can be explained on the assumption
that this General principle is operative
as an innate schematism
such a demonstration would provide
evidence in support of a finite
representation that observes the
principle
and against another finite
representation that violates it
in this and innumerable other ways s
might try to determine which of the
various imaginable finite
representations of the cognitive system
are plausible candidates for a theory of
the final state of his subject
on the basis of a postulated
representation of a cognitive system and
other assumptions about information
processing
s will try to explain many phenomena
such as why it is that his subject takes
two presentations to be the same face
but not to others
s will thus try to account for the fact
that his subject believes he is seeing
the same face twice
one might imagine various direct or
indirect ways in which such specific
beliefs and expectations could be tested
s might refer to the postulated
cognitive structure as a system of
beliefs
the finite representation postulated as
the subject's characterization of his
system of beliefs and many beliefs that
are implied by it will be unconscious No
Doubt and inaccessible to introspection
in many instances
the subject does Express beliefs
s will explain this fact
by showing how these expressed beliefs
follow from the finite representation
suppose that the subject expresses
beliefs that do not follow
or rejects beliefs that do or neither
accepts nor rejects beliefs that are
assigned to a definite status under this
characterization
or acts in such a way that s must
attribute to him beliefs that are
inconsistent with the characterization
then s will try to explain this result
in terms of the interaction of other
systems with the cognitive system of
belief
failing in this effort
he will have to revise the finite
representation
it may be expected that conscious
beliefs will form a scattered and
probably uninteresting subpart of the
full cognitive structure
at least if this is so
there should be no reason for surprise
nor do I see any objection to s's
practice in referring to the cognitive
structure attributed to the subject as a
system of beliefs
consider now the case of grammar
if s speaks English
he will say that some of his subjects
have learned French and now no French
furthermore in many specific instances
they can articulate their knowledge as
knowledge that so and so
again the set of such cases is unlikely
to be of much interest in itself
s will attempt to explain these
instances by showing how they follow
from the grammar of French
interacting with other cognitive
structures
in this way he will try to account for
facts analogous for French to those
mentioned earlier
the problems of Confirmation and choice
of theories are analogous to those that
arise in the case of Investigation of
Common Sense
obviously the grammar is not in itself a
theory of performance Behavior
it is however
proper for S to propose that the grammar
is a component of such a theory and to
proceed at this point to construct a
theory of interaction of structures
that would serve as a theory of
performance for his subjects
s might refer to the grammar attributed
to the speaker as a representation or
model of his knowledge of his language
s might also want to say that the
subject who knows the language knows the
grammar
and that in his initial State he knew
Universal grammar
thus as his subject differs from an
English speaker a rock or a bird in that
he knows the grammar of French
to use the suggested terminology
he is like an English speaker and
different from a rock or a bird
in that in his initial State he knew
Universal grammar
since some might object to this
terminology
s might prefer to invent some technical
terms
let us say that if a speaker knows the
language L then he cognizes l
furthermore
he cognizes the linguistic facts that he
knows
in any uncontroversial sense of no
and he cognizes the principles and rules
of his internalized grammar
both those that might be brought to
awareness and those that are forever
hidden from consciousness
furthermore
he cognizes the principles that underlie
the acquisition of language in the first
place
the principles of universal grammar
assuming that the approach outlined
earlier is correct
thus a person who knows English cognizes
certain facts for example
that necessarily Bachelors are unmarried
and that is goes with singular subjects
he also cognizes that specific rules are
ordered in a certain way relative to one
another
furthermore
the person cognizes the Transformations
apply in a cyclic ordering and Obey SSC
that initial phrase markers and surface
structures contribute to semantic
interpretation in ways described earlier
and the Transformations are structure
dependent
the latter examples constitute part of
innate cognization assuming that the
theory suggested earlier is correct
if we decide to use the word no in a
narrow sense
restricting it to conscious knowledge of
or to knowing how why who and so on
as this notion is often construed
then knowledge of as in knowledge of
language will have to be explicated in
terms of the new technical vocabulary so
it appears
in this usage
what is known will be a rather
ill-defined and perhaps a scattered and
chaotic subpart of the coherent and
important systems and structures that
are cognized
for psychology
the important notion will be cognized
not no
or we might make the decision to sharpen
and perhaps extend the term no so that
it has just the properties of cognize
thus eliminating the new terminology
then we will be able to explain explicit
knowledge of certain facts by showing
how these cases are related to the
system of tacit knowledge
I doubt that this question can be
settled by considerations of ordinary
usage which seemed to me vague and
inexplicit at just the crucial points
the philosophical tradition is varied
leibniz for one spoke of unconscious
knowledge
though he seems to have regarded all
knowledge as accessible to consciousness
Hume described instincts as those parts
of an animal's knowledge that it derives
from the original hand of nature
in contrast to the parts of knowledge
that it learns from observation
it seems to me that the principles that
determine our systems of knowledge and
belief
interact so completely and inseparably
with our knowledge in anyone's sense of
this term
that it would be difficult to develop a
coherent account that would isolate true
knowledge
however
it is unclear that more than
terminologies at stake here
thus s might choose to abandon the terms
knowledge and even knowledge of language
if some find that offensive
while noting that there is little
warrant and ordinary usage for these
decisions
if so he will speak of acquiring
cognizing and competence instead of
learning knowing and knowledge
as long as we are clear about what we
are doing either approach seems to me
quite all right
provided we agree about the thing it is
needless to dispute about the terms
Hume
consider now some of the objections that
have been raised to the approach
sketched above
I cannot survey the literature here but
will mention a few cases that I think
are typical
I will not consider further the question
that some philosophers seem to feel is
crucial namely
whether the term knowledge is properly
used in these accounts
Robert Schwartz argues that the fact
that we can specify a subject's
competence in terms of a formal system
of generative rules does not in itself
imply that he has represented a
corresponding system in him
this observation is surely correct
no non-trivial theory is ever implied by
the evidence available
but Schwartz apparently wants to say
something Beyond this truism
He suggests the following example to
illustrate the messy issue that he
thinks arises
suppose a certain device d labels
spheres positive if their density is
greater than one and negative if their
density is less
suppose that a system of equations e is
proposed involving relations between
volume density weight and so on
which describes the output of d
but Schwartz notes D might not employ a
set of principles anything like e
thus it might never consider weight
volume and so on
but might contain a liquid of density 1
and label positive any sphere that sinks
and negative any sphere that floats
would it be reasonable to claim that our
equations e are internally represented
in this machine
his answer is that it would not even
though in some sense the liquid in the
machine could not be held to stand for
the equations e
suppose that s observing d concluded
that its cognitive State involves
calculations of the sort expressed in e
further investigation might convince s
that this conclusion is wrong
and that a very different principle is
employed
namely the one Schwartz suggests
it would not of course be reasonable to
persist in maintaining the d employs a
set of principles anything like e
since this conclusion has been refuted
the fact that e continues to describe
input output relations correctly is
uninteresting to s
once he has discovered the actual
principles employed there is no messy
issue here
of course if s were simply satisfied to
say that e describes input output
relations
he would not have proceeded with further
investigation to determine whether D
actually employs principles like e
but as a scientist
s would have been interested to discover
what it is about D that makes e an
accurate description
to determine this
he might put forth the working
hypothesis that D actually calculates in
accordance with e
or that e enters in some important way
into the actual performance of d
and he would then seek evidence bearing
on this hypothesis
he would be interested to discover that
this hypothesis is false
no such inquiry would occur to someone
who was so lacking in curiosity as to
leave the matter with the statement that
e correctly describes regularities in
D's Behavior
but there seems no problem of principle
here
Schwartz observes that in the case of a
person riding a bicycle
any specific proposal as to the
organization of the system of habits and
skills involved
is subject to doubt
and as long as such doubt remains
care must be taken in interpreting the
assertion that the laws of physics
internally represented in some specific
fashion
model the subject's bicycle skills
again the observation is correct
since non-trivial theories are not
implied by data
care must always be taken when they are
proposed
I see absolutely no interest in this
observation
nor should s pay the least attention to
it
he already knew that he was engaged in
Empirical research
Schwartz seems to feel that something
more is at stake
but he gives no indication of what it
may be
and gives no reference to any work to
which these strictures seem at all
relevant
the preceding example has to do with s's
theory of Common Sense
but Schwartz applies the argument as
well to his theory of grammar
he notes that
any true description of regularities of
or within the set of grammatical
sentences will tautologically be true of
the output of the subject's competence
if we find a specific regularity in the
subject's language
then he might be said to know this
regularity but only in the sense that he
will consider strings that violate this
rule ungrammatical
these regularities then are regularities
true of what the subject knows the class
of grammatical sentences
and not regularities he knows
insofar as Schwartz is simply proposing
a usage for the term no
I see no interest in pursuing the
discussion
except to point out that it seems
curious to accept X knows the class of
grammatical sentences
and I suppose
X has learned rules that specify this
class
that is
X has learned a grammar but not X knows
the rules of his grammar
let us replace no by cognize in the
preceding discussion to avoid the
terminological issue
should we say then that the subject
cognizes the rules and regularities only
in the sense that he considers strings
that violate them ungrammatical
only if we are so lacking in curiosity
as to be unwilling to try to determine
whether a particular theory about the
subject is in fact correct
if s were satisfied to say only that
some Theory describes regularities true
of the class of sentences that the
subject cognizes
he would not conduct further
investigation to choose between this
Theory and some other Theory describing
the class of sentences in terms of some
different system of rules
but there surely are ways of
investigating alternative theories
thus consider the theory of English
sketched earlier
s might propose that the reciprocal rule
is a transformational rule moving each
and one to give each other and one
another from initial phrase markers of
the form each of NP
blank the other one of NP blank the
other
his colleague S Prime might propose
rather that each other and one another
are base derived
and interpreted by a semantic rule
s double Prime
might propose that the underlying
structures are conjunctions
if s s Prime and s double Prime are
satisfied to observe that their theories
describe correctly certain regularities
then further investigation stops
if they proceed in the manner of any
scientist to attribute cognitive
structures differing in these respects
to their subjects they will then proceed
to seek other data to choose among these
hypotheses
the evidence might be quite varied
for example it might derive from other
languages thus suppose that postulating
a transformational rule violates a
certain principle U
and that by taking U which say is
otherwise confirmed to be part of
universal grammar
we can explain certain facts in other
languages
just as SSC serves to explain certain
facts in English
on the empirical Assumption of
uniformity among humans with respect to
language acquisition
this evidence would serve to counter s's
assumption that the English-speaking
subjects are in fact making use of a
cognitive structure that involves a
transformational movement rule
thus the contrary theories of S Prime
and perhaps s double Prime receive some
indirect but valuable empirical
confirmation
many other kinds of evidence can be
sought
s s Prime and s double Prime have every
reason to take their hypotheses to be
working hypotheses concerning the steady
state attained by their subject
and thus subject to further confirmation
or disconfirmation
surely there can be no General objection
to the normal realist assumptions of any
scientist in this case
though obviously care must be taken Etc
perhaps what Schwartz has in mind is
something different
perhaps he has in mind a case in which
two theories are compatible with all the
evidence that might in principle be
obtained
if so
s should simply dismiss this
consideration as any working scientist
would
the notion all the evidence that might
in principle be obtained surely requires
some explanation
I doubt that any sense can be made of it
furthermore
even if we accept it as meaningful
nothing follows with regard to s's
Enterprise
in the real world he will never have
exhausted the evidence
and with diligence and Imagination can
seek new evidence to select between
empirically distinguishable theories
suppose that s comes up with several
theories as the best ones he can devise
without examination of the internal
structure of his subjects
then he will say regretfully that he
cannot determine on the basis of the
evidence available to him which if any
of these theories correctly
characterizes the actual internal
structure
in Schwartz a sphere example s will not
be able to determine whether e or rather
the account in terms of a liquid of
density 1 is the correct Theory
as in the case of the Spheres so in the
case of language
s will not be perplexed about the nature
of the theories he is proposing and
their relation to fact
rather he will be annoyed that he cannot
by hypothesis proceed to choose among
theories that seem plausible
in any event
there seems no reason for us to abandon
the standard procedure of any scientist
with its conventional realist
assumptions in such cases as these
Schwartz then proceeds to raise certain
objections to the study of language
learning as pursued by S
he feels that the psychologically
interesting question is whether the
factors that shape the learning of
language are specific to language or
whether they are General features of the
learning apparatus
he argues that the child develops many
skills and competences acquires
knowledge of relationships and
regularities in his environment
learns games and complex patterns of
social behavior
Etc
in essentially the same untaught manner
he learns language
and in these cases two standard
behavioral theories seem inadequate
yet it would he believes seem
implausible to claim distinct in Nate's
schemata responsible for each
he further suspects that there will be
no interesting version of the claim that
children would encounter enormous
difficulty learning a language not of
the predestined form
since children acquire complex symbol
systems that do not fit the natural
language mold
but would he argues be circular to claim
simply that any symbol system that
violates the Chomsky and canons is not a
language
and thus outside the scope of the claim
these remarks are offered in criticism
of chomsky's approach to language
learning
namely the one sketched earlier
taking his comments in turn it would
surely be interesting to determine
whether the factors that shape language
learning are specific or general
though it is curious to insist that this
is the psychologically interesting
question
thus suppose the question to be resolved
by Elementary observations such as those
noted earlier
which suggest that the factors that
shape language learning are specific
are there no psychologically interesting
questions left
perhaps this is true for someone wedded
to traditional Dogma
but surely many questions remain for a
scientist who would be interested to
discover the detailed character of the
factors that are involved in acquiring
various cognitive structures
the failure of familiar learning
theories to account for cognitive
structures apart from language is
repeatedly emphasized in the work that
Schwartz is criticizing
noting that other systems are learned
untaught and have complex properties
uniform among learners
one would naturally proceed as outlined
earlier in each such domain
determine the character of the system
acquired the evidence on the basis of
which it was acquired and the innate
factors that make possible the
acquisition of this system on the basis
of the available evidence
thus if the principles of structure
dependence SSC and so on appear to be
properties of the acquired system of
language
we will attempt to account for this fact
by postulating an innate mechanism
capable of determining these principles
on the basis of the available data
for reasons already discussed
it seems plausible to regard these
principles as comparable to those that
determine the nature and function of
organs
in other domains we find quite different
properties and will proceed in a
comparable way
postulating whatever innate structures
are required to explain the facts
Schwartz believes that it is implausible
to postulate distinct innate schemata
for different skills and competences
but since he offers no arguments we may
disregard the judgment
it has no more weight than the unargued
belief that embryos learn to have eyes
or that people learn to organize
perceptual Space by the mechanisms
involved in word association
there is no place for such dogmatic
claims
Schwartz never considers any of the
obvious reasons for doubting that there
is an undifferentiated learning theory
nor does he give any argument for his
beliefs
apart from the observation that many
skills and competences are learned
untaught
from which we can conclude only that a
theory that presupposes teaching is
wrong
Schwartz's claim of circularity is
obviously an error when s proposes that
Universal grammar has certain properties
he is advancing an empirical hypothesis
we may test it by studying the facts of
language
in principle
we might test the proposal by asking
whether a child will use language in
accordance with the principles put forth
even in the absence of evidence that
these principles apply
as in the cases discussed earlier
thus observing that no child ever makes
the mistake of producing 14 instead of
15. corresponding to the declarative 16
s might postulate that a property of the
child's initial State excludes the
structure-independent hypothesis 1 of
chapter 1. as unformulable
14.
is the man who tall is in the room
15.
is the man who is tall in the room
16.
the man who is tall is in the room
s might then proceed to ask whether the
other phenomena obey the principle
advanced
or he might proceed in principle to
construct an appropriate experimental
situation in which such examples as 14
and 15 are never presented
and ask whether subjects invariably use
the structure-dependent rule that gives
15 rather than 14.
if so he will have gained confirming
evidence for the empirical hypothesis
that the principle of structure
dependence is part of universal grammar
since that assumption provides an
explanation for the facts similar
remarks apply in the case of the more
complex examples discussed earlier
in practice because of conditions of
time and feasibility
more indirect tests must be sought
but the logic of the situation is clear
enough
and even the existence of tests that
could be used in principle suffices to
refute the charge of circularity
there is good reason to anticipate that
further research will support the
conclusion that principles of the sort
discussed earlier do constitute part of
the innate schematism for language
acquisition
thus it is surely implausible to suppose
that in the cases in question for
example 14 and 15
every child has had sufficient relevant
experience with appropriate examples
on the contrary
it is often a difficult problem even to
discover examples that bear on the
hypotheses in question
cssc
yet if we find that people observe these
principles
we must seek an explanation for this
fact
the only explanation that has been
proposed to my knowledge is the one
suggested before
the principles belong to Universal
grammar which is an element of the
initial state
but whether this proposal is right or
wrong there can be no doubt that the
project outlined is an empirical one at
every step
hence the charge of circularity is
surely false if it were Justified there
would be no point in testing specific
proposals say that SSC or the principle
of structure dependence belongs to
Universal grammar
being tautological the proposals could
not be false
for similar reasons we can readily see
why there might be and indeed already is
an interesting version
of the hypothesis that children would
encounter considerable difficulty in
learning languages that violated
postulated universals contrary to
Schwartz's contention
at least this is true if we take an
interesting version of the hypothesis to
be one that has far-reaching empirical
consequences and considerable
explanatory value
it is easy to see where Schwartz's
argument goes astray
in the first place he is overlooking the
fact that we have certain antecedently
clear cases of language as distinct from
maze running basket weaving
topographical orientation recognition of
faces or Melodies use of maps and so on
we cannot arbitrarily decide that
language is whatever meets some canons
we propose
thus we cannot simply stipulate that
rules are structure independent then
concluding that examples such as 14 and
15 are not relevant to language as
determined by this stipulation
of course there are unclear cases as
well and there is the constant problem
of determining when a theory must be
abandoned in the face of apparent
counter evidence
or when cognitive domains have been
improperly delimited in the first place
but these are hardly new problems unique
to this Enterprise
on the contrary they arise constantly in
any rational inquiry
furthermore
quite apart from the matter of
antecedently clear cases
recall that s is attempting to map out
the full system of cognitive structures
for his subject
determining their character and
interaction at each step making certain
idealizations and advancing empirical
hypotheses
hence taking steps that are not implied
by his data naturally
if he finds that other symbol systems do
not fit the natural language mold he
will try to determine what mold they do
fit he will study their character and
the basis for their acquisition
proceeding in the same manner as in his
study of language
untroubled by dogmatic beliefs about the
uniformity of learning
ultimately
s will hope to find that symbol systems
that fit different molds also have
different neural representations
and that the various innate factors
postulated to account for the facts will
also wear distinct have different
physical representations
little is known as yet but there is at
least evidence that essential linguistic
structures and functions are normally
represented in the left hemisphere and
that some of the other symbol systems
the Schwartz following Goodman
irrelevantly introduces into the
discussion are primarily controlled by
the right hemisphere
perhaps in areas homologous to the
language centers
non-speech sounds speech sounds not used
in the context of speech Melodies Etc
see chapter 2.
there also appear to be some differences
in the stage of maturation at which
various centers are established in their
function
recent work on face recognition reported
by Susan Carey is suggestive in this
regard
whether or not these tentative proposals
prove correct on further investigation
clearly they are of the sort that a
scientist concerned with symbol systems
their character interaction and
acquisition should explore
Schwartz seems to believe that any
departure from the natural language mold
in the case of other symbol systems must
be accidental
that is that any innate schematism for
language learning must simply be a
general schematism for learning
but he has offered no argument
whatsoever for this contention
and he simply ignores the many obvious
problems it faces
some mentioned earlier
the concerns about Theory and evidence
that Schwartz expresses
and his objections to the program
outlined earlier are typical of much
recent discussion
but the objections have no foundation
and the concerns where Justified at all
have no bearing on the issues so far as
I can see
in that they apply in a comparable way
to any variety of empirical inquiry
they are worth considering in detail
only because of the Insight they provide
into empiricist assumptions
if Schwartz's claims on these matters
had any Merit
they should apply as well to the study
of physical organs
suppose that s develops a theory t
dealing with the structure and function
of the human eye
and postulates the innate factors F to
account for the growth of an organ
satisfying t
suppose now that he turns his attention
to the liver
paraphrasing Schwartz we might argue
that it is implausible to postulate
distinct innate factors F Prime
which along with f and others constitute
the genetic coding that determines the
nature of the organism to account for
the growth of the liver
after all the eye and the liver are both
organs
and it would be circular to claim that
any organ not satisfying T is not an i
and thus outside the scope of the claim
embodied in F
or suppose that s decides to study the
eyes of mammals and insects
postulating different genetic mechanisms
to account for the Striking differences
in the final States attained and the
pattern of development
following Schwartz
we counter that he has committed a
logical error since the insect eye is
also an eye and it would be circular to
claim that an organ that violates the
theory of the mammalian eye is not a
mammalian eye
and thus outside the scope of the claim
concerning the basis for its development
plainly
none of this can be taken seriously
it is a question of fact whether map
Reading and language use involve the
same or similar mechanisms
for example SSC the principle of the
transformational cycle Etc
and whether the cognitive structures
involved develop on the basis of the
same or similar innate factors
the observation that we call both
language and Maps symbol systems
contributes no more to an inquiry into
their nature function and origin than
the observation that the mammalian and
the insect eye are called eyes
or that the I and the liver are called
organs
similarly the observation that both
symbol systems are learned is as
informative as the observation that both
organs develop
no conceptual argument can establish
that a scientist is wrong to postulate
fundamentally different cognitive or
physical structures
or to attempt to explain these
differences on the basis of distinct
innate factors
an empirical argument must be brought to
bear
this Schwartz entirely fails to do so
consequently his discussion is simply
beside the point
similar arguments are developed in
Atherton and Schwartz
much of their discussion is devoted to
refutation of positions on innateness
that have never appeared in the
literature to my knowledge
at the very end they point out that the
psychologist must postulate the
existence of whatever capacities can be
shown necessary for language mastery
but they assert to argue that the
feature is responsible for natural
language are so highly task specific
that they can be separated from
cognitive life in general would be to
strip the claim that natural language is
innately species specific of most of its
metaphysical as well as its theoretical
and philosophical interest
this remark which ends the paper
is the only observation they make which
has any real bearing on s's program or
familiar variants of it in earlier
discussion
apart from points already discussed
but there is a crucial logical slip in
their formulation
they assume without argument that if the
feature is responsible for natural
language are
highly task specific
than these features can be separated
from cognitive life in general
but this does not follow
correspondingly the assumption that the
eye involves highly specific mechanisms
does not imply that the features
responsible for the eye
can be separated from the general
physical or cognitive functioning of the
organism
given empiricist prejudice
the argument is perhaps comprehensible
thus on these assumptions
cognitive life in general
is a system developed incrementally by
means of Association conditioning habit
formation generalization induction
abstraction of certain specific kinds
that have been proposed I omit again
vacuous formulations of empiricist
theory
any highly specific system developed on
the basis of other principles will
therefore be separated from cognitive
life in general
abandoning empiricist Prejudice we will
explore various cognitive domains
attempting to map out their structures
interaction and function and to
determine the features responsible for
the cognitive structures that develop
as in the case of the physical structure
of an organism so in the case of its
cognitive organization
the discovery that some cognitive
structure develops on the basis of
Highly specific features implies nothing
about its relations however intimate to
other structures that enter into the
organism's cognitive state
as for the notion of metaphysical
theoretical or philosophical interest
since Atherton and Schwartz do not
explain what they mean I will drop the
matter
wvo Quine argues along somewhat similar
lines in his discussion of
methodological problems of linguistics
in a familiar terminology grammars are
said to be weakly equivalent if they
generate the same set of sentences and
strongly equivalent if they generate as
well the same set of structural
descriptions
Klein asks us to consider the following
situation
suppose that two grammars are
extensionally equivalent over the class
of sentences that is weekly equivalent
suppose further that both systems fit
the behavior of all us native speakers
of English
plainly these systems do not guide
behavior in the sense that the behavior
knows the rule and can state it and this
knowledge causes the behavior guiding is
a matter of cause and effect
but it would be wrong Quine holds to
suggest that English speech might be
rule guided in some other sense that is
unconsciously
in his View it is senseless to say that
two extensionally equivalent weekly
equivalent systems of grammatical rules
need not be equally correct
and that the right rules are the rules
that the native speakers themselves have
somehow implicitly in mind
what he rejects is the doctrine that
imputes to the natives and unconscious
preference for one system of rules over
another equally unconscious
which is extensionally equivalent to it
Quine accepts the notion of implicit and
unconscious Conformity to a rule
when this is merely a question of
fitting bodies obey in this sense the
laws of falling bodies an English
speakers obey in this sense any and all
of the extensionally equivalent systems
of grammar that demarcate the right
totality of well-formed English
sentences
these are acceptably clear dispositions
on the part of bodies and English
speakers
what Quine questions is my intermediate
notion of rules as heated inarticulately
the same considerations Quine argues
bear on the doctrine of linguistic
universals
timely reflection on method and evidence
should tend to stifle much of the talk
of linguistic universals He suggests
since such reflection will reveal that
there are distinct but extensionally
equivalent grammars
and it may be impossible to determine
unequivocally when apparent uniformities
are simply an artifact of the
translation process
coin believes that there is considerable
Folly in the proposals he criticizes
though it can be cured in time by
conscientious reflection on method and
evidence
he is willing to concede that some
course of inquiry might convince us that
there is indeed an unarticulated system
of grammatical rules
which is somehow implicit in the native
mind in a way that an extensionally
equivalent system is not
but he feels that clarification of
criteria has not been given sufficiently
for this enigmatic Doctrine
one can certainly sympathize with quines
plea against absolutism and his desire
for clarification of criteria
but nothing in his account suggests that
there is any problem here that has so
far gone unrecognized
or that there is any Folly to be cured
specifically I find no argument against
s's procedure
which of course is familiar from earlier
accounts or for that matter against any
account that appears in the literature
consider one of the few relevant
concrete cases that Klein discusses
namely the problem of choosing between
two extensionally equivalent grammars
one of which assigns to the sentence ABC
the immediate constituents a b POS C and
the other a pause BC
is there some Enigma here
I think not
though there are surely problems
proposals for solving the problems have
been advanced in the literature of
generative grammar since the outset
and I think that they are right in
principle though sometimes difficult to
apply in practice
suppose that s faces this problem
and does not think much of quine's
unimaginative suggestion
ask the natives
suppose that s has evidence to suggest
that intonation patterns are determined
by grammatical structure
the evidence might come from the
language in question or from other
languages
which are relevant for reasons already
discussed
such evidence might bear on the choice
between the two proposed grammars thus
we might discover that the rules needed
for other cases give the correct
intonation if we take the constituents
to be a pause BC but not a b pause C
or suppose that s has reason to
postulate the Transformations are
structure dependent in this sense
a transformation applies to a string
partitioned into a sequence of strings
Each of which is either arbitrary or is
a string of a single constant category
suppose that specific Transformations
say coordination observe constituent
structure in this sense
these principles which might be
supported by all sorts of evidence might
lead to a choice between the two
grammars in this case
say if we found that where a b c and a d
e are well formed then so is a pause BC
and d e
though where a b c and fgc are well
formed still a b and F G pause C is not
other evidence might be derived by
application of the principle that
contextual features of lexical items are
internal to constituents
or from semantic considerations of
varied sorts
given a rich general theory of universal
grammar s might bring many kinds of
evidence to bear on the question
examples abound in the literature
is there anything enigmatic in all of
this apart from the inescapable problems
of empirical uncertainty
I think not
at least Quine suggests nothing
here or elsewhere
quine's sole Point reduces to the
observation that there will always be
distinct theories that are compatible
with all the evidence at hand
that is true if we restrict ourselves as
he sometimes unreasonably suggests
to consideration of weak generation of
sentences
and it will remain true if we consider
as well a variety of other evidence
but this observation is without interest
again s already knew that his
non-trivial theories were
underdetermined by evidence
Quine has offered no reason to suppose
that s's investigation of language is
subject to some problem that does not
arise in his investigation of Common
Sense
or in any scientific investigation of
any subject matter
hence his strictures on method and on
linguistic universals and his General
charge of folly are entirely without
Force
though Quine does not explicitly invoke
his principle of indeterminacy of
translation in disconnection
it seems that his discussion here is
related to that principle
I have argued elsewhere
that this principle amounts to nothing
more than the observation that empirical
theories are underdetermined by evidence
Quine gives a counter-argument he
asserts that the indeterminacy of
translation is not just inherited as a
special case of the under determination
of our theory of nature
it is parallel but additional
his argument is as follows
17.
consider from this realistic point of
view the totality of truths of nature
known and unknown observable and
unobservable past and future
the point about indeterminacy of
translation is that it withstands even
all this truth the whole truth about
nature
this is what I mean by saying that where
indeterminacy of translation applies
there is no real question of right
choice
there is no fact of the matter even to
within the acknowledged under
determination of a theory of nature
the remarks of 17 constitute quine's
full answer to my query
in what respect does the problem of
determining truth in the study of
language differ from the problem of
physics
quine's realistic point of view takes
theory in physics as an ultimate
parameter that is
we go on reasoning and affirming as best
we can within our ever underdetermined
and evolving theory of nature
which includes ourselves as natural
objects
with this our scientist s of course
agrees
and he studies language exactly as he
studies physics
taking humans to be natural objects
quine's formulation 17. merely
reiterates his belief that somehow
indeterminacy of translation
actually what is at stake on quine's
grounds is the status of all
propositions about language that face
more than his ordinary inductive
uncertainty hence virtually all of the
non-trivial study of language
withstands all of the truth about nature
the remark 17 is false if the study of
translation is part of the theory of
Nature and true otherwise
but quine's assertion 17 gives no reason
to doubt that the theory of translation
is part of the theory of nature hence
underdetermined by evidence only as
physics is
and this was the only point at issue
similarly when kwine asserts that there
is no fact of the matter no question of
right choice he is once again merely
reiterating an unargued claim which does
not become more persuasive on repetition
if the underdetermination of physical
Theory by evidence does not lead us to
abandon the realistic point of view with
regard to physical Theory then the
comparable underdetermination of
grammatical Theory by evidence does not
support quine's claim that there is no
fact of the matter in this domain to be
right or wrong about
for example in the case of the
constituent analysis of the sentence ABC
the rule of NP proposing SSC the
principles of semantic interpretation
discussed in chapter 3 a theory of the
meaning of a word or whatever
neither here nor elsewhere has Quine
given any argument whatsoever to justify
his assertion that statements about
language that go beyond his notion of
ordinary induction with its
uncertainties are subject to some
methodological doubts that do not hold
in principle in any non-trivial
empirical study
his thesis of indeterminacy thus has no
support beyond the truism the theory is
underdetermined by evidence in Empirical
research
a consistent skepticism will lead one to
challenge any empirical assertion about
the natural world
thus noting the underdetermination of a
theory of nature we can pointlessly
observe that given any proposed
non-trivial physical Theory there are
alternatives compatible with all
available evidence
if we are willing to follow Quine in
granting some sense to the notion of
totality of evidence
the same statement can be made about a
theory compatible with the totality of
evidence
correspondingly in the case of
propositions of the theory of language
that are not derived by ordinary
induction
we can observe equally pointlessly
that there are alternatives compatible
with the evidence
Quine urges a change in prevalent
attitudes toward meaning idea
proposition
we must abandon the conviction that our
sentences express ideas and express
these ideas rather than those even when
behavioral criteria can never say which
depending on how we interpret behavioral
criteria quine's assertion is either
indefensible in that it imposes
conditions on the study of language that
cannot generally be met in empirical
inquiry
or it is correct but simply goes to show
that the study of language and
translation is in principle On a par
with physics
consider two theoretical propositions of
the theory of language P which asserts
that sentence s expresses these ideas
and P Prime which asserts that s
expresses those ideas
suppose we interpret the phrase
behavioral criteria inquines dictum as
meaning necessary and sufficient
conditions couched in terms of
observation
then we cannot expect that p and p Prime
will be differentiated by behavioral
criteria
but quine's proposal so understood is
unreasonable in the theoretical Concepts
and propositions employing them can
rarely be provided with criteria in this
sense
and there is no justification for
imposing such a requirement on this
branch of empirical inquiry alone
suppose we interpret the phrase
behavioral criteria as meaning simply
relevant evidence
thus what is proposed is that we abandon
the conviction that P differs
empirically from P Prime
where there is no relevant evidence
bearing on the choice between them
but with this proposal the scientists
will readily agree
in this respect
the study of language specifically
translation is on a par with other
branches of empirical science
to choose between p and p Prime
we will seek relevant evidence
which might be indirect and will in
general be inconclusive that is
not logically compelling though perhaps
compelling as we will see directly
Juan vacillates between these two senses
of Behavioral criteria
whichever interpretation we pick the
proper conclusions are unsurprising and
do not differentiate the study of
language or translation
from physics in principle
one might argue that such Concepts as
meaning idea proposition
have no place in the study of language
thus one might argue that relevant
evidence will never exist for
theoretical statements employing these
Concepts
or that there is a better theory that
avoids them entirely
but accounts for the relevant evidence
but this kind of critique
Justified or not rests on no novel
notion of indeterminacy
rather the issue is in principle just
like those that arise in other branches
of empirical inquiry
wine pursues a similar line of argument
he points out correctly that whatever
problems bedevil translation also appear
in the case of our own language
that is if there is some problem of
principle affecting the hypothesis that
the natives govern guy translates our
term rabbit then the same problem arises
in asking whether our terms rabbit
rabbit part number Etc really refer
respectively to rabbits rabbit Parts
numbers
Etc
rather than to some ingeniously permuted
denotations
the question Quine holds is meaningless
except relative to some background
language
solution to the Dilemma is that in
practice we end the regress of
background languages in discussions of
reference by acquiescing in our mother
tongue and taking its words at face
value
but this is no help at all
since every question that he has raised
can be raised about the mother tongue
and the face value of its words
in fact there was no interesting problem
in the first place
apart from the underdetermination of
theory by evidence
Quine has yet to pose any problem that
should trouble a natural scientist
taking the course suggested for s
a scientist who regards people as
natural objects and their use of
language a part of nature
to be studied in a familiar way
in the same article Quine argues that
semantics is vitiated by a pernicious
mentalism as long as we regard a man's
semantics as somehow determinate in his
mind beyond what might be implicit in
his dispositions to overt Behavior
is the problem here the reference to
mind
or is it the gap between what is
regarded as determinant and what is
implicit in dispositions
suppose that we replace Mind by brain in
quine's formulation
is there something pernicious now
or suppose we reformulate quine's thesis
as follows
science is vitiated by a pernicious
physicalism so long as we regard an
object's State structure
a somehow determinate in its physical
Constitution body beyond what might be
implicit in its dispositions
is the latter thesis to be taken
seriously
surely not
but then neither is the former
at least on any grounds that Quine
suggests
as far as I can see quine's thesis of
indeterminacy of translation and its
several variants
amounts to no more than an unargued
claim that the study of language faces
some problem over and above the Familiar
underdetermination of non-trivial theory
by evidence
but I think that quine's position on
this matter is not only unargued but
also of doubtful consistency
thus consider the following formulation
learning by as tension is learning by
simple induction and the mechanism of
such learning is conditioning but this
method is notoriously incapable of
carrying us far in language
this is why on the translational side we
are soon driven to what I've called
analytical hypotheses the as yet unknown
innate structures additional to Mere
quality space that are needed in
language learning are needed
specifically to get the child over this
great hump that lies Beyond as tension
or induction
if chomsky's anti-impericism or
anti-behaviorism says merely that
conditioning is insufficient to explain
language learning then the doctrine is
of a peace with my doctrine of the
indeterminacy of translation
consider the as yet unknown innate
structures mentioned in this passage
since they are as yet unknown presumably
they are knowable
or to put it more properly hypotheses
concerning these innate structures have
exactly the status of propositions of
Natural Science
and in fact are simply a part of biology
consider then a set of hypotheses H1
concerning these innate structures
needed in language learning to get the
child past the limitations of extension
or induction
examining these hypotheses
the scientist s might derive a new set
of hypotheses H2 concerning the class of
systems that can be attained by an
organism equipped with the innate
structures characterized by H1
he might sharpen these hypotheses H2 by
considering the nature of the available
evidence but for Simplicity
let us put this consideration aside
the hypotheses H2 also falls strictly
within Natural Science in principle and
raise no new questions of indeterminacy
clearly we can make no a priori
assumptions about the hypotheses H1 and
H2
they are to be discovered tested refined
by the methods of the Natural Sciences
it is in particular surely possible that
H2 will have bearing on the choice of
alternative phrase structure analyzes
for example a pause BC versus a b pause
C
on the principle SSC on the theory of
surface structure semantic
interpretation on the trace theory of
movement rules
or on the nature and properties of
nameable objects for example rabbits and
rabbit stages and all sorts of other
matters
the hypotheses H2 Express properties of
language that cannot be determined by
the child by the linguist by the methods
of extension or induction
but looking back at quine's earlier
account
it was precisely the hypotheses of this
character that were allegedly subject to
indeterminacy of translation
a new problem that does not arise in the
Natural Sciences
presumably it is for this reason that
Klein notes that the doctrine under
discussion is of a peace with my quines
doctrine of the indeterminacy of
translation
recall however that where indeterminacy
of translation applies
there is no real question of right
choice
there is no fact of the matter even to
within the acknowledged under
determination of a theory of nature
apparently then the hypotheses H1 and H2
have nothing to be right or wrong about
and cannot be selected confirmed refined
or rejected in the manner of the Natural
Sciences
although they are as we have seen
perfectly ordinary hypotheses of human
biology dealing with as yet unknown
hence knowable innate biological
structures and the restrictions and
scope they entail with regard to what is
learned
in short it appears that Quine is
committed to the belief that this
specific part of biology is subjected to
some new problem of principle that does
not arise elsewhere in the Natural
Sciences
despite his earlier claim that the whole
truth about nature was immune to this
strange indeterminacy
it is difficult to see how one might
reconcile these various contentions
I return to other apparent internal
contradictions incline's doctrines on
these matters in a moment
consider finally quine's claim that
English speakers obey any and all
extensionally equivalent systems of
grammar in just the sense that bodies
obey the law of falling bodies
this is a singularly misleading analogy
the rules of English grammar do not
determine what speakers will do in
anything remotely like the sense in
which the law of falling bodies
determines that if people jump from a
building they will hit the ground in a
specifiable Time
all that the rules of grammar tell us is
that a person will ideally understand
and analyze a sentence in certain ways
not others a very different matter
but even putting this fundamental
difference aside to be consistent Quine
should I believe reformulate his claim
English speakers obey any and all of the
extensionally equivalent English
grammars whether we consider weak or
strong equivalents or some still
stronger notion involving even richer
empirical conditions
in just the sense in which bodies obey
the law of falling bodies or the laws of
some other system of physics that is
extensionally equivalent
with respect to some given class of
evidence
put this way the claim is quite
uninteresting for just the reasons
already discussed
physicists do not need to be cured of
the Folly of assuming that the laws they
postulate are true
and of seeking evidence to choose among
alternative systems that are so far
compatible with evidence nor does s have
to be cured of the analogous Folly when
he is studying a particular organism as
part of the natural world
part of the interest of the study of
language
if conducted in the manner outlined for
S is that it shows the inadequacy of
quine's Notions fitting and guiding for
the study of human behavior
a person's behavior is not in general
consciously Guided by rules in quine's
sense of the term
and we can go well beyond the assertion
that it simply fits rules inclined sense
rather the scientist can proceed in the
normal way to postulate that his theory
of humans in fact is true
that humans have the characteristics the
mental organization the cognitive
systems attributed to them under the
best theory he can devise
and on this standard realist assumption
just the assumption that quine's
physicist adopts
s will proceed to seek evidence that
will confirm or disconfirm his theories
of human nature and competence
he will try to choose among alternative
theories that are compatible with the
evidence so far available
ultimately we hope the investigator will
go on to ask whether his theory is
confirmed by the study of the central
nervous system Again
unperturbed by The Inevitable under
determination of theory by evidence
pursuing quine's methodological
discussion a step further
equine objects to what he terms my
nihilistic attitude toward dispositions
and rejection of dispositions
this seems to him so odd that he adds
I'd like to think that I am missing
something
indeed he is
a look at the statements of mind that he
partially cites makes it quite clear
what he is missing
his belief that I reject dispositions is
based on my criticism of his definition
of language as a complex of present
dispositions to verbal behavior in which
speakers of the same language have
perforce come to resemble one another
Quine quotes the following remarks from
one of my essays
presumably
a complex of dispositions is a structure
that can be represented as a set of
probabilities for utterances in certain
definable circumstances
but it must be recognized that the
notion probability of a sentence is an
entirely useless one
on empirical grounds the probability of
my producing some given sentence of
English is indistinguishable from the
probability of my producing a given
sentence of Japanese
however Quine omitted phrases in the
quote which should read as
presumably a complex of dispositions is
a structure that can be represented as a
set of probabilities for utterances in
certain definable circumstances or
situations
but it must be recognized that the
notion probability of a sentence is an
entirely useless one under any known
interpretation of this term
on empirical grounds the probability of
my producing some given sentence of
English is indistinguishable from the
probability of my producing a given
sentence of Japanese
introduction of the notion of
probability relative to a situation
changes nothing at least if situations
are characterized on any known objective
grounds
he then says that he is puzzled by how
quickly he Chomsky turns his back on the
crucial phrase in certain definable
circumstances
then he adds that verbal dispositions
would be idle if not defined in terms of
specific circumstances
his puzzlement derives from his omission
of the final sentence of the quoted
section
which notes that introduction of
circumstances helps his case not at all
kwine further adds that he has
talked mainly of verbal dispositions in
a very specific circumstance
a questionnaire Circumstance the
circumstance of being offered a sentence
for Ascent or dissent or indecision or
bizarreness reaction
but as I noted this simply makes matters
worse
plainly a language is not a complex of
dispositions to respond under the
particular set of gadunkan experiments
that Klein considers
nor did Quine make this patently false
claim in the work I was discussing
since Quine insists on the same point
elsewhere
perhaps a further word is an order
Quine is concerned here to allay a
curious criticism
namely
my criticism of his characterization of
a language as a complex of dispositions
to verbal Behavior
he cites the same comment from my essay
again omitting the final sentence which
notes that his case is in no way
improved if we consider probability
relative to a situation and the further
discussion of this point
he then makes the following comment
let us not forget that dispositions have
their conditions
the probability that a given lump of
salt will dissolve at time T is as may
be
but the probability that it will
dissolve if immersed in water is high
chomsky's worry may have been a more
specific difficulty
that of setting conditions for the
triggering of verbal dispositions
this is an important problem
and happily it has an easy solution a
solution indeed that was prominent in
the book that Chomsky was commenting on
it is the procedure of query and descent
which I shall take up in section 12.
section 12 is an elaboration of the
procedure of query and Ascent of Quine
in this section Quine discusses the
continuing Enterprise of ostensive
learning what he calls statement
learning
he is concerned with the learning of
ascent for example the way that a child
learns to say yes in the presence of the
color red and the sound red
unfortunately this procedure even if we
grant that it has the role in language
learning that Klein proposes has no
bearing whatsoever on the questions that
I raised a language Quine held is a
complex of present dispositions to
verbal Behavior
if we suppose that a complex of
dispositions can be represented as a set
of probabilities for utterances in
certain specifiable circumstances
a supposition that Quine apparently
accepts
we Face a series of problems that I
pointed out
no way of assigning probabilities to
utterances on empirical grounds relative
to situations seems to offer any hope of
salvaging quine's characterization of
language
as a complex of dispositions to verbal
Behavior
I noted further that clearly however
the person's total disposition to verbal
response under arbitrary stimulus
conditions is not the same as his
dispositions to be prompted to assent or
to dissent from the sentence under the
particular conditions of quine's query
and Ascent procedure
quine's assertion that the problem of
setting the conditions for the
triggering of verbal dispositions is
solved by the query and descent
procedure can only mean that he is
failing to make this crucial distinction
taking his proposal literally
we must conclude that a language is a
complex of dispositions to assent or
dissent under the conditions of the
query and descent procedure
but this is plainly not the case
I see no other interpretation of his
claim that the problems of
characterizing utterance probability in
situations and thus salvaging his
definition of language as a complex of
dispositions to respond recall that this
is what is at issue has an easy solution
in terms of his procedure of query and
descent
I suspect that quine's failure to deal
with the numerous and fundamental
problems that stand in the way of his
proposals derives from his continuing
belief that the child learns most of
language by hearing the adults and
emulating them
if a child learns most of language by
hearing an emulation and esquine
elsewhere insists
learning a language is a matter of
learning sentences then the child must
learn most of his sentences by hearing
and emulation
but this is so grossly false that one
can only wonder what Quine may have in
mind
particularly since elsewhere he observes
correctly that a language is an infinite
system
characterized by a generative grammar
and further that conditioning induction
and extension do not suffice for
language learning
perhaps what Quine means is nothing more
than the truism that speakers adults
provide the child with the data for
language learning
but on this interpretation
the child learns all not most of
language by hearing the adults or other
speakers
and the comment so understood
loses any relevance to the discussion in
which it appears
the comments I made in my essay apply
without modification to quine's more
recent formulations
I also went on there to make the obvious
point that if a language is a complex of
dispositions to respond under a normal
set of circumstances
it would be not only finite unless it
included all languages but also
extremely small
for reasons they are explained
I also pointed out that Quine avoids the
multitude of problems that arise if his
account is taken seriously by shifting
his ground from totality of speech
dispositions 2. dispositions to be
prompted to Ascent or to dissent from
the sentence
a set of dispositions which he claims
constitutes all of the evidence
available in principle to the linguist
now in my remarks there is no rejection
of dispositions but rather a false or
empty statements about dispositions for
example the statement that a language is
a complex of present dispositions to
verbal Behavior
quine's response deals with none of the
issues raised
he responds that dispositions to assent
or dissent are surely within the
totality of speech dispositions
true but irrelevant
and that resort to this subset does not
avoid the problems but solves them
surely false
and he notes that the problem of
distinguishing Japanese from English on
empirical grounds does not bear on his
experiments concerning dispositions to
assent and dissent
true but irrelevant
obviously these remarks were accurate
have no relation to any of the points
raised in my comments
in my essay I pointed out that in
earlier work Quine had also misused the
notion disposition namely
in his proposal that synonymy roughly
consists in approximate likeness in the
situations which evoke two forms and
approximate likeness in the effect of
the hearer
this proposal is untenable compare the
statements watch out you'll fall down
the stairs and watch out you'll fall
down the sequence of steps arranged one
behind and above the other in such a way
as to permit assent or descent from one
level to another
consider the situations which evoke
these two synonymous utterances and
their effects on hearers
Quine is not alone in this kind of
misformulation
William Alston suggests that a statement
of the form X means why is Justified to
the extent that when X is substituted
for y in a wide variety of sentences
and vice versa the dispositions of
members of the linguistic Community with
respect to employing sentences for the
performance of linguistic action is in
each case roughly the same for the
sentence produced by the alternation as
for the sentence which was altered
again the example just cited and
innumerable others like it show at once
that this statement is far from the mark
it is all very well to try to relate
comments about meaning speech acts and
so on to behavior
but not at the expense of factual
accuracy
in fact to deal with these matters I
believe one must pursue the course
outlined earlier for the scientist s
abstracting to the competence that
underlies language use
in the theory of competence it may be
possible to make sense of some notion of
synonymy but direct analyzes in terms of
dispositions so far as I can see
are quite hopeless
again I stress that these remarks do not
imply a rejection of dispositions on the
contrary I suggest that we take the
notion disposition to respond seriously
thus concluding that quine's proposed
formulations are quite wrong I believe
irremediably so
my remarks on efforts to Define language
in terms of dispositions to respond and
on probability of utterances in
definable circumstances are also
discussed by supis
he objects that these remarks are
written without familiarity with the way
in which probability concepts are
actually used in science
his reason is that in considering even
the simplest probabilistic phenomenon
say coin flipping we may be dealing with
probability of outcome approaching zero
but it in no sense follows that the
concept of probability
cannot be applied in a meaningful way to
the flipping of a coin
similarly
there are many probabilistic predictions
about verbal behavior that can be made
ranging from trivial predictions about
whether a given speaker will utter an
English or Japanese sentence to detailed
predictions about grammatical or
semantic structure
thus our inability to predict the unique
flow of discourse no more invalidates a
definition of language as a complex of
dispositions to verbal Behavior
then our inability to predict the
trajectory of a single free electron for
some short period of time invalidates
quantum mechanics
these remarks are completely beside the
point
supis has failed entirely to understand
the questions that were at issue in the
discussion to which he refers
it is correct that given a grammar we
can develop sophisticated applications
of probability Theory untroubled by the
fact that the basic objects of
Investigation have either extremely
small probabilities or strictly zero
probabilities
given a characterization of English and
Japanese by a grammar we can make
predictions as to whether a given
speaker will utter a sentence of English
or Japanese so characterized
but it is equally correct that lacking a
characterization of The Language by a
generative system
or some approximation there too
we can make little sense of empirical
observations of the probability of
utterances
whether an empirically definable
circumstances
or in some Corpus of utterances
in particular we can make no sensible
predictions as to whether the next
utterance will be English or something
else
the analogy to Quantum Mechanics is
quite false
physicists do not characterize the
theory of quantum mechanics as a complex
of dispositions of electrons to move
here or there as experimentally observed
rather they develop a theory of such
movements and related to experimental
observation a totally different matter
if a language is defined as a complex of
dispositions to verbal Behavior
determined simply in terms of
probability of response in given
situations without reference to any
postulated theory of competence we will
be faced with the mass of problems I
mentioned
if on the other hand the complex of
dispositions is expressed in terms of a
postulated theory of competence all of
the questions at issue are begged
in the same connection supis objects to
the imperialistic Ambitions that many
linguists seem to have for a theory of
competence vis-a-vis the theory of
performance and claims that the two can
proceed independently
he does not explain what he has in mind
in referring to these imperialistic
ambitions
but presumably
he is thinking of the contention that
the study of performance use of language
can progress only to the extent that we
have some understanding of the system
that is used
the latter contention however
is hardly imperialistic
rather it is close to truism
thus if all we know about language is
that it consists of words
we can study the use of words and
construct probabilistic models for word
sequences
on the other hand
if we know something about grammatical
or semantic structure
then we can proceed as supi's proposes
we do to construct probabilistic models
that provide detailed predictions about
these postulated structures
the probabilistic grammar that supis
discusses makes use of a classification
of questions on syntactic and semantic
grounds
that is it presupposes a partial theory
of competence that provides such a
classification
his own examples illustrate the truism
that the theory of language use cannot
sensibly proceed independently of the
theory of competence
no imperialistic Ambitions have been
expressed Beyond this truism
as for soupy's contention that neither
of these theories need precede the other
if by proceed he means temporarily
proceed of course there can be no
objection
the study of language is concerned with
the system and its use
the linguist is thus concerned with the
competence Acquired and performance
models that incorporate this competence
and are concerned with its use
it is impossible to lay down upper Yuri
conditions as to the points in this
complex system
at which new insights will arise
I fail to see any issue here
soupy's properly endorses quines plea
against absolutism
but he seems to have some misconception
as to the nature of the work to which he
eludes
since Quine has been perhaps the leading
critic of the project suggested earlier
for the scientist s
it may be helpful to consider further
his remarks on the study of language
as I read Quine we must distinguish two
different and I believe inconsistent
doctrines
here is the first
a theory and also a language is a fabric
of sentences variously Associated to one
another
and to non-verbal stimuli by the
mechanism of conditioned response
and Quine goes on to specify three
mechanisms by which sentences can be
learned
Association of sentences with sentences
Association of sentences with stimuli
and analogic synthesis
a notion left obscure apart from a
single example
namely a case of substitution of one
word for another in a given context
he also defines a language as a complex
of present dispositions to verbal
behavior in which speakers of the same
language have perforce come to resemble
one another
a formulation which as already noted is
either empty or wrong
depending on how we introduce situations
learning also involves a quality space
with dimensions and a distance measure
to be determined experimentally
in fact the denizens of the quality
space are expressly stimulations any and
all with no prior imposition of
dimensions
any irrelevant features of the
stimulations will in principle disappear
of themselves in the course of the
experimental determination of the
quality space
which can be explored and plotted
by behavioral tests in the differential
conditioning and Extinction of his
responses
the final dimensionality of someone's
quality space if wanted
would be settled only after all the
simply ordinal comparisons of distance
had been got by the differential
conditioning and Extinction tests
by considerations of neatest
accommodation along the lines of Goodman
now consider the proposals of Quine in
the late 1960s
he states that the method of
conditioning is notoriously incapable of
carrying us far in language
and takes his doctrine of the
indeterminacy of translation of a peace
with the doctrine that conditioning is
insufficient to explain language
learning
he insists that generative grammar is
what mainly distinguishes language from
sub-human communication systems
and he speaks of the as yet unknown
innate structures additional to Mere
quality space
that are needed in language learning to
get the child over this great hump that
lies Beyond ostension or induction
he also adds an explicit word of welcome
toward any innate mechanisms of language
aptitude however elaborate that can be
made intelligible and plausible
while in 1960 Klein was following the
skinarian pattern as he repeatedly
States
in the later work he defines behaviorism
merely as the view that all criteria
must be couched in observation terms and
that conjectures must eventually be made
sense of in terms of external
observation so that behaviorism is just
another name for weak verificationism
I see no way to reconcile the earlier
and later views
if conditioning is insufficient to
explain language learning
then a language is not a fabric of
sentences and stimuli Associated by
conditioned response
and sentences are not learned by the
three mechanisms of 1960.
if generative grammar is the essential
defining characteristic of human
language
then again the earlier account can be
dismissed since a generative grammar can
be described neither as a fabric of
sentences and stimuli Associated by
conditioning
nor as a complex of dispositions to
respond
if innate mechanisms of arbitrary
complexity are permissible so long as
conjectures are eventually made sense of
in terms of external observations
then there is no reason to assign any
special place to dimensional structures
such as a quality space nor to
structures determined by differential
conditioning and Extinction tests as
distincts say from recall or recognition
tests
quine's later views seem to me an almost
complete abandonment of behaviorism and
all of its trappings in my opinion a
welcome move
I say almost complete because in the
more recent version the notion
conditioned response still plays a role
one that seems to me highly dubious
but
it seems to me more interesting that
quine's later views do not fall within
the class of systems e
though the earlier version does in so
far as it is clear
thus if we are prepared to welcome any
innate mechanism however elaborate we
are not bound to procedures of the
character of e but can explore richer
and I believe more adequate theories
coin's discussion of this important
matter obscures the central issues
Quine suggests that by rationalism
I mean simply the principle that innate
structures must be rich enough to
account for language acquisition
while not so rich as to be incompatible
with data and he expresses his agreement
with this indisputable point about
language
he then adds that innate biases and
dispositions are the Cornerstone of
behaviorism
and that Beyond qualitative spacing of
stimulations
unquestionably much additional innate
structure is needed to
to account for language learning
his empiricism or behaviorism will
apparently welcome any account of these
innate endowments so long as conjectures
can eventually be made sense of in terms
of external observations
thus his behaviorism or externalized
empiricism
can certainly accommodate my rationalist
alternative
but I nowhere suggested that rationalism
was to be construed in the way kwine
proposes
rather
I suggested that there are two general
approaches R and E Each of which
postulates innate mechanisms
but mechanisms of very different sorts
as explained at some length
obviously R and E or any rational
inquiry should satisfy the indisputable
point about language which he cites
I suggested further that this
requirement cannot be satisfied by any
approach of the character of E in
particular by the approach of Quine
which I argued can be subsumed within e
in so far as it is not vacuous
kwine's response that behaviorism also
postulates innate mechanisms is plainly
irrelevant to any issue that was under
discussion
consider now the roles still assigned to
conditioning in quine's more recent
suggestions
these are two
18. a quality space is to be determined
by conditioning experiments
19. conditioned response does retain a
key role in language learning
it is the entering wedge to any
particular lexicon
for it is how we learn observation terms
or better simple observation sentences
by extension
learning by Ascension is learning by
simple induction and the mechanism of
such learning is conditioning which is
notoriously incapable of carrying us far
in language
as for 18
it is doubtful that a quality space can
be determined in any sensible way in
isolation from other innate cognitive
structures
conditioning experiments can be devised
to show that people can associate
geometrical objects by shape by area by
position in visual space
and for all I know by time of day when
presented
experiments can probably be devised to
show that people generalize from one
presentation of a face to another
that does not match it in the sense of
Goodman
for example a right and left profile
or that they generalize in terms of
Dimensions determined by a notion of
matching of Faces in Goodman sense
furthermore contrary to quine's
contention
there is no justification for the belief
that Goodman's methods whatever their
interest in their own right
have any privileged position for the
investigation of a quality space
a scientist investigating human
cognitive structures might construct an
abstract quality space as part of the
full integrated system
but I see no reason to suppose that it
has a more primitive character than
other components of the system
or that it can be determined in
isolation
or that a reasonable hypothesis about a
quality space is less infected by
theoretical considerations with their
indeterminacies than other components of
innate cognitive structure
or that relevant experiments for
determining dimensionality can be
selected in isolation from the general
theory of innate cognitive structure
thus both the commitment to a particular
class of experiments conditioning and
Extinction
and the commitment to an isolable
quality space with some privileged
character seemed to me Highly
Questionable
consider 19. in the first place I see no
way to make sense of the statement that
the mechanism of learning by simple
induction is conditioning
but there are more serious issues
recall that according to the 1960 Theory
induction leads to genuine hypotheses
with normal inductive uncertainty
as distinct from the analytical
hypotheses that exceed anything implicit
in any native's disposition to speech
Behavior
and further in using such analytical
hypotheses say in proposing that they
constitute part of a generative grammar
we impute our sense of linguistic
analogy
unverifiably to the native mind
recall that virtually all of syntax as
well as most semantics consists of
analytical hypotheses
the imputation is unverifiable because
of the alleged problems of indeterminacy
as already noted
Quine seems to have now implicitly
rejected all or part of this Doctrine
but it seems that incline's present view
the mechanisms namely conditioning that
account for learning of observation
terms are still qualitatively different
from those involved in other aspects of
language learning
however
I see no reason to suppose that there is
any fundamental difference in this
regard
putting to the side now quine's concerns
over indeterminacy
consider what is perhaps the most
Elementary notion we have
the notion physical object
which I suppose plays a role in the most
Elementary processes of learning through
ostension induction or conditioning
but the notion physical object seems to
be quite complex
at the very least
some notion of spatio-temporal
contiguity seems to be involved
we do not regard a herd of cattle as a
physical object
but rather as a collection
though there would be no logical
incoherence in the notion of a scattered
object esquine Goodman and others have
made clear
but even spatio-temporal contiguity does
not suffice as a general condition
One Wing of an airplane is an object but
its left half though equally continuous
is not
clearly some Gestalt property or some
notion of function is playing a role
furthermore scattered entities can be
taken to be single physical objects
under some conditions
consider a picket fence with breaks
or a caldermobile the latter is a thing
whereas a collection of leaves on a tree
is not
the reason apparently is that the mobile
is created by an act of human will
if this is correct then beliefs about
human will and action and intention play
a crucial role in determining even the
most simple and Elementary of Concepts
whether such factors are involved at
early levels of maturation I do not know
but it is clearly an empirical issue and
dogmatic assumptions are out of place
it may be that a schematism of
considerable complexity and abstractness
is brought to bear in learning processes
that might be regarded as very
Elementary
whatever sense can be made of this
notion very little sense I am suggesting
we are I think LED back again to the
piercing view mentioned earlier
and I think that even Klein's newer
Doctrine involves empirical claims of a
most dubious sort
see chapter 2.
I have dwelt on these matters at such
length because I believe that the
problem of choosing between systems of
the general character of R and E
or some combined Doctrine is a very
significant one
I've argued elsewhere
that these two approaches expressed
leading ideas of rationalists and
empiricist speculation
Quine believes that little is at stake
but for the reasons just explained
I think he is mistaken
others have taken a similar view
Jonathan Cohen suggests that the
arguments I gave against e show only
that techniques of simple enumeration
are inadequate for language learning
or construction of scientific theories
Etc
but these arguments do not bear on the
techniques of eliminative induction
the letter R adequate for scientific
discovery and may also be adequate for
language learning
thus we need not indulge in the
relatively extravagant Assumption of
innate linguistic universals
the problem with Cohen's proposal is
that there do not exist techniques of
eliminative induction
in any relevant sense for eliminative
induction to proceed we need some
specification of the class of admissible
hypotheses in Pierce's sense
or at least some ordering of
admissibility perhaps partial
the theory of universal grammar as
sketched here and in the reference is
cited is one such specification
of the character of r
but the systems that fall within e as I
outlined it fail to provide a
specification of admissible hypotheses
that offers any hope of accounting for
the facts
if the method of eliminative induction
is supplemented with an initial
schematism that limits the class of
humanely possible grammars it will fall
within r
if it is not so supplemented
it is empty
if it is supplemented in this way it
will Express the Assumption of innate
linguistic universals which is not only
not extravagant but so far as I know
unavoidable
Cohen presents a number of arguments
against assuming innate universals
he points out analogies between language
acquisition and scientific discovery
concluding that by parody of reasoning
if the Assumption of innate linguistic
universals is required for the first
then some analogous assumption is
required for the second
this conclusion he takes to be more or
less a reductio ad absurdum
to account for scientific discovery he
argues it suffices to postulate the
general capacity for eliminative
induction
why not then assume that this capacity
suffices for language learning as well
but Cohen's argument fails for reasons
already discussed
the scientist s casting a finer net than
Cohen notes the analogies between
language acquisition and scientific
discovery
and also notes fundamental qualitative
differences already discussed
these would lead him I have argued to
postulate a system of innate linguistic
universals
but as s proceeds to map out the full
cognitive system of his subjects he will
also try to develop principles that
account for scientific discovery
recognizing that a general capacity for
eliminative induction is entirely
vacuous and leads nowhere unless there
is a specification of a class of
admissible hypotheses or some ordering
of admissibility
he will try to determine the
specification
for reasons already noted it is likely
to be very different from the system of
linguistic universals that characterizes
admissible grammars
where the systems one and the same
the fundamental differences between
acquisition of language and Common Sense
on the one hand
and knowledge of physics on the other
would be inexplicable
it is quite possible that s would
postulate a theory of the character of r
with innate universals to account for
the ability to gain scientific knowledge
in fact I know of no coherent
alternative
basically Cohen's arguments fail because
of their vagueness the substantive
content of a learning theory
is largely determined by the
specification of admissible hypotheses
if my proposal is correct
since we know nothing about the basis
for scientific discovery
we can only speculate
but insofar as
parody of reasoning has any force it
would lead us to suspect that in this
domain as well
the substantive content of any adequate
Theory will be given by a
characterization of admissible
hypotheses
as Pierce argued
surely nothing is gained by invoking the
vacuous concept eliminative induction
The Emptiness of this proposal can be
seen at once if we ask the simplest
question
how in principle
could we program a computer to carry out
eliminative induction in the case of
language acquisition or scientific
discovery
in the absence of constraints on
admissible hypotheses
Cohen's discussion of eliminative
induction tacitly concedes this point
by presupposing as an element of this
method
a conception of what is to count as a
hypothesis inter Alia
Cohen then suggests a further line of
argument
he claims that postulating an innate
ability to do X in order to explain how
it is that children are able to do X
allegedly without learning from
experience is a tautological pretense
and to avoid this triviality it is
necessary to discover
consequences that are testable
independently of the language learning
facts it purports to explain
for example
some consequences for brain physiology
or for the treatment of speech disorders
alternatively we must abandon the
hypothesis that there are language
specific mechanisms
but since the Chomsky in theory does
lack independently testable consequences
of this kind it seems that theoretical
progress in the explanation of language
learning
should not be sought in the direction of
richer and richer theories of innate
universals as Chomsky suggests but in
the direction of less and less specific
theories of innate endowment that will
account for such linguistic universals
as there appear to be
no one doubts the importance of
searching for consequences of linguistic
Theory beyond the language learning
facts
but
consider Cohen's argument which rests on
the assumption that postulating an
innate ability to do X to explain how it
is that children are able to do X is a
tautological pretense
is Cohen's assumption correct
suppose that the scientist s postulates
the structure-dependent property of
rules sdp or the principle SSC as an
element of universal grammar thus he
postulates that children do not learn
these principles but rather construct a
linguistic system
observing these principles
thus s is postulating an innate ability
to observe these principles in order to
explain how it is the children observe
those principles without learning from
experience
by Cohen's assumption
s's hypothesis is a tautological
pretense and therefore cannot be
falsified
but in fact it can be falsified all too
easily Say by further investigation that
shows that sdp or SSC is violated
elsewhere in the language or in some
other language
in fact
proposals concerning Universal grammar
hence on the interpretation suggested
earlier proposals concerning innate
capacity have repeatedly been revised on
just such grounds
thus Cohen's initial assumption is false
and his argument collapses
the theories of universal grammar so far
proposed
though not a tautological pretense as
Cohen falsely alleges are still far from
sufficiently Rich and restrictive to
explain acquisition of language
they do not sufficiently limit the class
of admissible hypotheses
thus contrary to what Cohen asserts
it seems that theoretical progress in
the explanation of language learning
should be sought in the direction of
richer theories of innate universals
at least until some other approaches
suggested that has some degree of
plausibility
Cohen's suggestion that we seek less and
less specific theories of innate
endowment that subsume linguistic
universals merely expresses once again
the conventional belief that the
language faculty has no special
properties
that there is simply a generalized
learning capacity
but like others who are committed to
this belief
he gives no plausible argument for it
and does not face the obvious problems
that arise in maintaining this View
it would be necessary rather than simply
desirable to search for evidence in some
other domain say neurophysiology only if
we had reached the point of constructing
adequate theories that could not be
distinguished empirically without such
further Evidence
this remark is indeed a triviality
but one that has no bearing on the
non-totological character of explanatory
hypotheses formulated in the terms
outlined earlier
that is in terms of apostolated
schematism of universal grammar
notice that if experiments with humans
were possible
s could obtain evidence relevant to
theories of universal grammar in many
other ways
thus he could test his assumption that
sdp and SSC
form part of universal grammar by
exposing children to invented systems
violating the proposed conditions and
determining how or whether they manage
to acquire these systems
if acquisition of such systems is
possible
but qualitatively different from
acquisition of natural language
if say it has the properties of
scientific discovery
then s will take this as confirmatory
evidence for his theory that sdp and SSC
form part of the language faculty
which is one of the several faculties of
mind
the fact that such experimental
procedures are possible in principle
again demonstrates the non-todological
character of the explanatory theories in
question
in this connection Cohen argues that if
a Martian's language violated a proposed
theory of universal grammar but were
learnable by humans this result would
show that Universal grammar does not
mirror human linguistic capacities
therefore he concludes
if we adopt the assumption that there
are innate linguistic universals we must
scour the whole universe not just the
Earth in pursuit of intelligible exotic
languages
thus the project is unfeasible
this argument fails for two reasons
first it is based on a fundamental
misunderstanding of the nature of
scientific inquiry and second the
formulation is once again
too imprecise to have any bearing on the
issues
consider the first failing
we note at once that there is no
distinction between a martian language
and any invented language
thus we need not scour the universe to
discover possible counter examples to a
proposed Theory to be presented to human
subjects in a learning test
rather we can freely invent such counter
instances given a proposed theory of
universal grammar that provides a system
of innate linguistic universals we can
at once construct languages that violate
the postulate principles and seek to
determine in one or another way
whether they are accessible to humans in
the manner of natural language
we can continue this search for
disconfirming evidence indefinitely and
in many ways
if this makes the original project
unfeasible as Cohen claims eliminating
now his irrelevant reference to scouring
the universe
than any empirical inquiry is unfeasible
on exactly the same grounds
once again Cohen's discussion of Martian
languages
merely underscores the obvious
non-trivial empirical theory is
underdetermined by evidence
furthermore
Cohen's discussion is crucially
imprecise on the matter of learnability
suppose that we have a theory ug of
universal grammar
suppose that we have a system L Martian
or invented a distinction of no account
violating the innate linguistic
universals postulated in ug
suppose we find that L is learnable by
humans exactly in the manner of attested
human languages
that is under comparable conditions of
time and exposure to data with
comparable success and so on
then we reject Yuji just as we would
reject it if we found evidence from a
tested human languages contradicting its
assumptions
suppose however that we find that L is
learnable only as physics is learnable
this discovery does not refute ug just
as ug is not refuted by the observation
that college students can learn
theoretical physics a theory that no
doubt violates the principles of ug
obviously the mind has capacities beyond
the language faculty and the fact that
physics or Martian is learnable in
itself proves nothing about the language
capacity
finally
Cohen argues that simpler approaches
suffice to account for language
acquisition
and he sketches a few possibilities
unfortunately the latter do not begin to
deal with even the most Elementary
properties of language that have been
discussed in the literature
for example the property of structure
dependence
consequently his proposals cannot be
taken seriously as they stand
as for the further possibility that
ability to use Transformations May
simply be a special case of some generic
skill
this proposal is entirely empty until
the generic skill in question is
specified
and the proposal is not particularly
plausible for reasons already mentioned
Cohen's discussion is one of the best
and most accurate that I have found
but I think he has given no serious
argument for any of his conclusions
Cohen points out that if the approach he
is criticizing is a reasonable one and
if its specific conclusions do receive
some confirmation then the case for a de
jury approach to the semantics of
natural languages is considerably
strengthened in a sense of De jury
approach that he develops and rejects
since his arguments against the general
approach lack any force and since there
is at least some confirmation for it it
follows that the de jury approach to
semantics of natural languages is
considerably strengthened
contrary to his intentions if his
reasoning in this regard is correct
Cohen's failure to confront the only
interesting questions that arise in the
case of language learning is revealed
still more clearly in his more elaborate
discussion of the question
where He suggests again that with a
proper concept of eliminative induction
one can overcome the arguments that a
language learning system should have the
character of r
and he argues further on the same
grounds that a general learning strategy
should be able to do the job
his proposed method of induction
presupposes first of all a certain set
of materially similar Universal
hypotheses where material similarity is
defined over a subject matter
and secondly a set of natural variables
that are inductively relevant to such
hypotheses and further it presupposes
some method for modifying hypotheses for
moving to higher order hypotheses and
for idealizing and rejecting certain
data
these methods remain unspecified
but unfortunately for his argument the
question at issue was the nature and
source of the initial set of universal
hypotheses and the natural variables
and about this question Cohen has
nothing to say
in my book aspects of the theory of
syntax 1965 and elsewhere it was argued
that the delimitation of these
hypotheses must be in terms of
principles of the character of R rather
than e
and many specific proposals were put
forth
Cohen's approach is so vague and
inexplicit that we cannot tell whether
it falls within r or e
nor can we discover any of its relevant
properties from his account
he merely stipulates that his General
learning strategy is based on an
unspecified initial set of hypotheses a
technique unspecified for modifying
hypotheses a choice unspecified of
relevant variables an initial limitation
to relatively few Concepts
which are unspecified
and so on
there can be no objection to an
inductive language learning device which
is a formulator and tester of hypotheses
with a nicest toward generalization that
will lead it to formulate hypotheses
about relationships between the relevant
variables which will subsume and explain
as it were
the more Elementary hypotheses that have
already been established
none of the questions that concern us
are clarified by these remarks or by
references to the continuity of
inductive methodology from first order
Elementary generalizations through
second order correlational
generalizations to third order
theoretical generalizations
or by assuming a device that always
hypothesizes as boldly as it can about
its initially noticed data
contrary to what Cohen asserts no light
seems to be shed by the proposed account
of inductive reasoning
for the simple reason that the proposed
account reduces to hand waving at every
crucial point
Cohen believes that in syntax the number
of relevant variables is vastly fewer
and their size vastly smaller and
hypotheses are much more easily tested
than in most fields of Natural Science
this he claims is the reason why
children learn language more quickly
than we solve problems in Natural
Science
I doubt that he would maintain this
thesis if he were to attempt to
formulate the principles that govern
language and its use
he also suggests that the more abstract
the concepts that are invoked in
linguistic Theory the more plausible it
is to suppose that if innate at all
these Concepts represent certain General
abilities
that have indefinitely many applications
but he gives no credible argument for
this thesis Beyond such claims is the
following it is certainly not obvious
that the structure dependence of say an
interrogative transformation is
substantially different from the
structure dependence of an individual
jump
in the children's game of hopscotch
but it seems obvious that the two are
substantially different
since even the notion of abstract phrase
structure does not appear in the
children's game
so that the notion of structure
dependence has no non-trivial
application in this case
Cohen also observes that one has yet to
read in the psychological literature of
an English speaker for whom there is
adequately attested evidence both that
he knows some such syntactic feature and
that he has never experienced any
evidence for it
this is true for quite uninteresting
reasons
no one has ever collected the entire
linguistic experience of any speaker
consequently we do not know for sure
that particular speakers who observe the
principle of structure dependence for
example have not explicitly been taught
that they are to produce 15
complementizer John believed Open
Bracket s complementizer Mary said Open
Bracket s complementizer Tom saw wh
someone double close brackets
rather than 14.
complementizer John discovered Open
Bracket NP pictures of who
close bracket
though the belief that in every case
relevant instruction or evidence has
been provided surely strains credulity
again the issue is plainly an empirical
one
and if one wish to undertake the tedious
task of demonstrating that speakers
observe the principle without having
been instructed that 14 and similar
cases are improper
he would know how to proceed
in short Cohen's belief that he has
shown the importance of inductive logic
for an adequate theory of language or
that he has given some argument against
learning theories of the form of r
or some argument in support of General
learning strategies is entirely without
Foundation
he has simply avoided all of the
questions that have been under
discussion the arguments bearing on the
choice of an approach of the character
of r or e and the arguments in support
of the theory that Universal grammar
specifies in Nate linguistic universals
of the sort that have been extensively
discussed
are Untouched by his discussion
we can no doubt define empiricism as an
approach which includes theories of all
imaginable types in particular theories
of the character of both are and E
but this terminological suggestion is of
no interest
it remains true that the substantive
theories discussed within the empiricist
framework are of the form of E and are
inadequate for the reasons that have
been discussed at length in the
literature and again in earlier
discussion here
incidentally Cohen's explicit
disparagement of hume's approach amounts
to nothing more than a preference for
vacuous suggestions over fairly concrete
but wrong proposals
Cohen argues that the real issue is not
the issue between humanism on the one
hand and rationalism on the other
that is between e and r in the sense
outlined earlier
rather
the real issue is about the scope and
nature of General learning strategies as
against specific ones
but if the latter is the real issue then
we can only conclude that the real issue
has yet to be formulated in any
meaningful terms no General learning
strategies
have been formulated that have even a
remote relation to the actual problems
that arise when one attempts to account
for human learning in such domains as
language acquisition
though there are a few specific ones
that have been proposed that appear to
have some plausibility and empirical
support
for reasons already discussed it seems
doubtful that there exists General
learning strategies of much interest or
significance though of course one must
keep an open mind on this
Cohen's contention that the real issue
is about the scope and nature of General
learning strategies
reflects again the dogmatic beliefs
about the structure of human cognitive
capacities that are enshrined in the
empiricist tradition
I see nothing in his discussion to
suggest that there is any cogency or
plausibility in this traditional
Doctrine
John Searle has also suggested that
nothing much is at stake in the re
opposition that I have suggested as a
kind of rational reconstruction of
certain traditional and modern views
referring to a passage from leibniz
which I cited he comments that if this
is the correct model for innate
structure as I imply then at least some
of the dispute between Chomsky and the
empiricist learning theorists will
dissolve like so much Mist on a hot
morning
since many of the fiercest partisans of
empiricist and behaviorist learning
theories are willing to concede that the
child has innate learning capacities
in the sense that he has innate
dispositions inclinations and natural
potentialities
it should be clear from preceding
discussion that Cyril has also missed
the central point
in proposing two conflicting approaches
I explicitly stated that each postulates
innate dispositions inclinations and
natural potentialities
the two approaches differ in what they
take these to be in the case of e the
dispositions are the mechanisms of data
processing I outlined which give
something akin to quines genuine
hypotheses in the case of R the
dispositions specify the form of the
resulting systems of knowledge and
belief roughly they relate to analytical
hypotheses in what seems to be Quine
sense
the basic Point seems to me fairly clear
in the passages from leibniz that I
cited
as Alan geworth pointed out in response
to Searle leibniz draws two distinctions
where the empiricists draw only one
namely leibniz distinguishes Powers
which are passive indeterminate and
remote from dispositions which are
active determinate and proximate
Powers as such require the stimulation
of external objects both in order to be
activated and in order to receive their
perceptual or ideational contents hence
they have no specific contents of Their
Own
dispositions on the other hand already
have determinate contents which the mind
can itself activate given appropriate
external occasions
both powers and dispositions may be
called capacities
but then they are capacities of two
quite different sorts
according to this leibnizian model then
for ideas to be innate as dispositions
means that the mind has quite
determinate contents of its own which it
is itself able to activate and perceive
whereas for ideas to be innate merely as
Powers would mean that the mind has only
diffuse mechanisms whose contents are
exhaustively derived from the impact of
external stimuli as leibniz frequently
emphasizes
the latter model unlike the former is
unable to explain how the mind can
attain the sorts of necessary and
Universal truths found in logic
mathematics and other disciplines
and a comparable sort of necessity and
universality are attributed by Chomsky
to the basic rules of grammar
far from being compatible with
empiricist and behaviorist learning
theories as surl and Quine hold that it
is
leibniz's Doctrine shows how the mind
can itself be the exhaustive source of
its linguistic competence
for which external stimuli serve only as
occasions for activating what is already
dispositionally contained
in the mind's own structure
leibniz's Doctrine therefore explains as
the behaviorist theory cannot
the necessity and universality of the
linguistic rules for forming and
interpreting sentences
heworth's comments are exactly to the
point
The crucial question is not whether
there are innate potentialities or
innate structure no rational person
denies this
nor has the question been at issue
The crucial question is whether this
structure is of the character of e or r
whether it is of the character of powers
or dispositions whether it is a passive
system of incremental data processing
habit formation and induction or an
active system which is the source of
linguistic competence as well as other
systems of knowledge and belief
a similar distinction is made by
Descartes in passages which I quoted
he takes the cognitive power to be a
faculty that is not purely passive and
that is properly called mind when it
either forms new ideas in the fancy or
attends to those already formed
acting in a way that is not completely
under the control of sense or
imagination or memory
there is in humans he argues a passive
faculty of perception and an active
faculty capable of forming and producing
ideas
Searle argues that both my historical
claim that my views on language were
prefigured by the 17th century
rationalists especially Descartes and my
theoretical claim that empiricist
learning theory cannot account for the
acquisition of language are more tenuous
than I suggest
the theoretical claim is more tenuous
because empiricist learning theories
also accept innate dispositions he cites
in particular Quine already discussed
I hope it is now clear why searl's
argument with respect to my theoretical
claim is beside the point
as for the historical claim Searle gives
two reasons for his conclusion
first
did not suggest that the syntax of
natural languages was innate but rather
appears to have thought that language
was arbitrary
second
decath does not allow for the
possibility of unconscious knowledge
a notion that is crucial to chomsky's
system
but Cyril has mistaken the historical
claim I nowhere suggested that Descartes
views on language prefigured mine in any
of the respects Earl mentions
rather I opened my discussion of decath
by noting that he makes only scant
reference to language in his writings
my point was that Descartes
investigation of the creative aspect of
language use pre-figures current ideas
Searle agrees and that certain Cartesian
ideas were developed in the subsequent
study of language by others
furthermore Cartesian psychology
contributes to a coherent doctrine that
can be drawn from work that I reviewed
as for the second objection the notion
unconscious cognization is crucial to my
system and I am prepared to use
unconscious knowledge in this sense
but I am not at all sure that descat
would disallow this notion
though I recall taking no stand on the
matter
true Descartes seems to insist that
knowledge is accessible to consciousness
but on this entirely different point
I have explained repeatedly that I think
we must depart from the classical
Traditions thus searle's objections to
my historical claim are without any
Force
objections to these historical claims
have been made by others I will discuss
only one last example namely Barnes
since it raises questions that relate to
the foregoing discussion unfortunately
Barnes is rather careless in his
references
thus he asserts that Chomsky frequently
and emphatically maintains that his
adoption of the innate hypothesis
endorses the rationalism of decath and
leibniz and casts out the empiricism of
luck
citing sections of my books
my references to Descartes leibniz and
others are adequately qualified so far
as I know
Barnes cites no counter example nor have
others to my knowledge
and there is no discussion at all in the
cited reference of the empiricism of
luck
in my book Cartesian Linguistics 1966
Locke is not mentioned
and
in my book aspects of the theory of
syntax 1965
there are only two references to luck
one stating that he did not refute the
doctrine of innate ideas in the form in
which presented it and the other
that Luck's remarks on the origin of
ideas seems similar in respects noted to
cudworths in fact I have never even
discussed let alone cast out the
empiricism of luck
the only further evidence that Barnes
cites in support of his contention that
I give frequent and emphatic endorsement
to the rationalism of decath and leibniz
is my statement that contemporary
research supports a theory of
psychological apriore principles that
bears a striking resemblance to the
classical doctrine of innate ideas
Barnes neglects to add that in
elaborating this statement I noted
explicitly that my conclusion seemed to
me fully in accord only with certain
specific aspects of this Doctrine namely
Descartes theory of perception of
regular figures and leibniz's remarks on
innate and unconscious principles and
ideas and truths that are innate as
inclinations and so on
and this adequately qualified assertion
is so far as I know accurate enough
Barnes also refers in this connection to
my essay Linguistics and philosophy 1969
where the only comment even marginally
relevant is this
I think that a case can be made that
certain well-founded conclusions about
the nature of language do bear on
traditional philosophical questions
specifically
these conclusions are relevant to the
problem of how knowledge is acquired and
how the character of human knowledge is
determined by certain General properties
of the Mind
again I find no emphatic endorsement of
the sort He suggests
Barnes also claims that I use terms
promiscuously thus he agrees with the
conclusion that my theory is essentially
an irreparably vague his examples of
promiscuous use of terms are the
following
from aspects of the theory of syntax
which glosses innate grammar as innate
predisposition to learn a language
from Linguistics and philosophy
1969 which explicates innate grammar as
innate schematism
however neither citation exists
rather in the first case I state that an
innate linguistic Theory provides the
basis for language learning
and that we can use the term theory of
language with systematic ambiguity to
refer to the child's innate
predisposition to learn a language of a
certain type and to the linguists
account of this
the linguistic Theory specifies the form
of the grammar of a possible human
language but is not a grammar let alone
an innate grammar the second reference
that Barnes cites states that the child
makes use of an innate schematism that
restricts the choice of grammars
furthermore there is no reason why we
should not suppose that the child is
born with a perfect knowledge of
universal grammar that is with a fixed
schematism that he uses in the ways
described earlier in acquiring language
nowhere do I use the term innate grammar
note that Universal grammar is not one
of the set of grammars made available by
linguistic Theory
rather it is a schematism that
determines the form and character of
grammars and the principles by which
grammars operate
barnes's references suggest that he may
be confused about this point
however when his misreading is corrected
there is so far as I can see no
promiscuous use of terms and no
vagueness or confusion that arises from
the thesis that an innate schematism of
the sort discussed determines an innate
predisposition to learn a language of a
certain type
Barnes asserts that on occasion I speak
the language of crude in natism
embracing innate principles and even
innate grammars but I never Embrace
innate grammars except in the quite
appropriate sense just mentioned namely
innate Universal grammar and my use of
innate principles and Universal grammar
as an innate schematism is so far as I
can see subject to no criticism that
Barnes develops in his discussion of
crude in natism
Barnes then notes three alleged major
divergencies between Chomsky and his
classical forebears
the first is that neither leibniz or any
other classical innatist had any
particular interest in declaring the
principles of grammar to be innate
as for leibniz the remark is irrelevant
since I cited him only in reference to
other aspects of the general set of
doctrines that I was surveying but if
Kodama
and others whom I discussed are
classical in natist then I think a good
case can be made that they did regard as
innate certain principles that we would
regard as principles of grammar though I
developed this view again in a manner
which seems to me sufficiently and
properly qualified
Barnes also adds that as distinct from
my classical forebears I am not
concerned to establish the foundations
of science religion and morality that
too is incorrect
I am much interested in establishing the
foundations of Science and morality at
least though I regret that I have little
of interest to say about these questions
the second of the major divergencies is
that leibniz uses arguments that are
quite different from mine
this observation is irrelevant to the
extent that it is true
I cited leibniz where relevant to my
concerns and also cited a wide range of
arguments that differ from leibnizes
though they fall within the classical
rationalist Traditions that I surveyed
under the rubric of Cartesian
linguistics
as this is defined in Cartesian
linguistics 1966.
barnes's third Divergence is that the
classical innatists take P to be innate
in X's mind if x has an innate
disposition to know that P
whereas my view is that P is innate in
X's mind if x has an innate disposition
to Phi and being disposed to Phi is or
entails knowing that P
he does not explain why I am committed
to the latter View and reject the former
in fact under any sensible notion of
disposition and any non-trivial choice
of Phi that is unless Phi is taken to be
something like learn a language with
entails properly qualified in his
formulation
I see no reason to take either of these
formulations seriously
Barn seems impelled to offer some
quasi-operationalist characterization of
the concept of innate in X's mind
but I see no reason to expect such an
approach to be more successful in this
domain than it is elsewhere in
scientific inquiry
furthermore
barnes's formulation does not comprehend
the range of cases discussed by
classical and natists
in particular it does not apply to the
cases I cited as particularly
interesting such as cudworth's theory of
perception
but even if there is some point buried
here I do not see its bearing on
anything that I have discussed or
proposed
I have repeatedly emphasized far more
striking and significant departures from
the views of the classical in natists in
the Reconstruction that I have suggested
Barnes then raises the question
whether the existence of these innate
mechanisms requires the ascription of
innate knowledge to potential language
learners
I have already explained why I think
that his qualms in this regard are
unwarranted
but he adds some new errors that perhaps
Merit a word of clarification
he interprets the claim that some
principal say the principle of cyclic
rules of sdp or SSC is innate as the
claim that the child has an innate
disposition to speak as the principle
requires
and he argues that from the fact that an
organism has an innate disposition to
act in accordance with some rule or
principle we cannot infer that it has
knowledge of the rule or principle
it is wrong he argues to identify items
of knowledge or belief with dispositions
my dispositions he points out are
neither dispositions towards certain
fairly Elementary types of behavior nor
dispositions to assent to a proposition
the only two cases in which one might
conceivably identify items of knowledge
or belief with dispositions so he
maintains
barnes's discussion of this point is
vitiated by his failure throughout to
distinguish competence from performance
a principle such as the one he cites
cyclic application rules
taken as part of universal grammar is
not a disposition to speak as the
principle requires but rather a
disposition if one insists on this term
to acquire a certain competence that is
a certain cognitive structure a grammar
knowledge of language
having acquired this cognitive structure
a person may be disposed to speak in
certain ways although as I have
indicated there is little of substance
that we can say about this matter
it is perfectly true as Barnes points
out that if a bird is disposed to fly in
accordance with the laws of aerodynamics
we need not attribute to it knowledge of
these laws
for such reasons as the following one we
have or believe that we can construct an
explanation for its behavior in terms of
reflex structures and the like and two
the structural organization that we so
attribute to a bird plays no role in
accounting for its knowledge of any
particular things
in the case of linguistic dispositions
neither one nor two holds we might
regard Universal grammar as a
disposition to acquire certain
competence but not as a disposition to
behave in certain ways
and Universal grammar I have argued is
intricately an inseparably interwoven in
the mature system of knowledge of
language
on the basis of the system of universal
grammar the organism comes to know the
language and to no particular linguistic
facts
assuming the existence of this innate
system
we can account for such knowledge
Barnes asks what then is there about
innate linguistic dispositions that
might exalt their status to the rank of
knowledge
recognizing that these are dispositions
to acquire a system of knowledge
knowledge of language which underlies
knowledge of particular linguistic facts
the answer seems evident
although as I have already observed
there is a vagueness and imprecision in
the normal usage of no that might lead
us to a place no by the technical term
cognize throughout this discussion as a
matter of little moment so far as I can
see
Barnes is quite right in observing that
my dispositions do not fall under either
of the categories He suggests
but this fact simply illustrates once
again the inadequacy of such an analysis
of dispositions with its failure to
distinguish competence from performance
to recognize the intellectual component
in non-trivial instances of knowing how
its limitations to the inadequate
framework of fitting and guiding and
related matters already discussed
when we consider dispositions that fall
Beyond barnes's impoverished framework
for example the disposition to acquire
knowledge of language
then I believe reasons can be Advanced
for speaking of elements of these
dispositions as items of knowledge or
belief the difference being Irrelevant
in the case of language for familiar
reasons
in proposing that R and E represent two
fundamentally different ways of
approaching the problems of learning
and correspondingly the origin and
nature of knowledge I have always
insisted that I regard the question as
an empirical one
it is the problem of determining what
are in fact the specific properties of
the human mind in particular the
properties of what may be called The
Language faculty
a number of critics have argued that by
formulating the issue as an empirical
hypothesis I am eliminating any
philosophical interest
and removing the whole matter from the
concerns of the classical Traditions
that I have discussed in this effort at
rational reconstruction
as for the matter of philosophical
interest
I take no stand
the term is too vague and attitudes
among those who call themselves
philosophers are too varied
would I have argued is that the
empirical hypotheses I have been
investigating do have bearing on what
philosophers have said both in the past
for example Hume and the present for
example Quine who would surely reject
any sharp distinction between
philosophical and scientific issues
one of the more interesting question
whether by formulating the matter
explicitly in terms of conflicting
empirical hypotheses I am removing the
discussion beyond recognition from the
concerns of traditional debate
I can only comment briefly on this but I
think that the criticism is quite
mistaken
it is a mistake to read Descartes the
minor cartesians Hume and others as if
they accepted some Modern distinction
between scientific and philosophical
concerns
or as if they made a distinction between
necessary and contingent along the lines
of much current discussion
consider Hume he understood moral
philosophy to be the science of human
nature
his concern was to discover the secret
Springs and principles by which the
human mind is actuated in its operations
and he likened this task to that of the
philosopher who determined the laws and
forces by which the Revolutions of the
planets are governed and directed
he wished to undertake an accurate
scrutiny into the powers and faculties
of human nature and to discover the
operations of the mind this being no
inconsiderable part of science it cannot
be doubted Hume insisted that the mind
is endowed with several powers and
faculties that these powers are distinct
from each other that what is really
distinct to the immediate perception may
be distinguished by reflection
and consequently that there is a truth
and falsehood in all propositions on
this subject and a truth and falsehood
which lie not beyond the compass of
human understanding he makes interesting
and substantive claims concerning these
empirical issues for example that the
creative power of the Mind amounts to no
more than the faculty of compounding
transposing augmenting or diminishing
the materials afforded Us by the senses
and experience and that the only three
principles of connection among ideas are
resemblance contiguity in time or place
and cause or effect
the reasonings from experience on which
almost all knowledge depends involve a
step taken by the mind on the basis of
custom or habit a principle of human
nature these operations of the Mind are
a species of Natural Instincts an
instinct or mechanical tendency
thus they are unavoidable when the mind
is placed in certain circumstances
throughout Hume takes himself to be
studying the relation of knowledge to
experience and the empirical principles
that determine this relation
he observes that though animals learn
many parts of their knowledge from
observation there are also many parts of
it which they derive from the original
hand of nature
these we denominate instincts similarly
the experimental reasoning itself which
we possess in common with beasts and on
which the whole conduct of life depends
is nothing but a species of instinct or
mechanical Power
that acts in US unknown to ourselves
undirected by our intellectual faculties
by virtue of these instincts experience
is the foundation of moral reasoning
which concerns matter of fact and
existence
which forms the greater part of human
knowledge
throughout Hume is offering substantive
proposals about questions that we surely
regard as scientific questions as he did
too it seems clear
he is discussing the instinctive
foundations of knowledge including
unconscious and even innate knowledge
surely an empirical matter as he
correctly understood the question
similarly decaf could not have answered
the question whether he was a scientist
or a philosopher in the sense of these
terms used by many contemporaries who
restrict philosophy to some kind of
conceptual analysis
he was surely both
his approach to innate ideas and mind is
a case in point
as a scientist he thought he could
explain much of human behavior and
everything else in terms of mechanical
principles
but he felt compelled to postulate a
second substance whose Essence is
thought to account for observations
about humans himself and others it is
not at all correct to assert as many do
that his doctrine of innate ideas is an
effort solely to account for necessary
truths as this notion is understood in
contemporary discussion
within the framework of a theory of
innate ideas
developed a theory of perception for
example
but obviously his theory of perception
or cudworth's theory of the innate
cognositive power with its Gestalt
properties and related structure goes
well beyond the domain of necessary
truths as understood at present
though it was a different matter for the
man who believed that he had proved the
existence of a God who is no Deceiver
and who thus believed that he could show
the necessity of all laws of nature
plainly decath's concept of necessity
was quite different at least in presumed
extension from our own
it is quite wrong to claim that the
tradition was paradigmatically
philosophical in its concerns
at least if paradigmatically
philosophical is to be opposed to
scientific
correspondingly it seems to me entirely
appropriate to suggest the rational
reconstructions R and E as I have
as expressions of some of the leading
ideas of rationalist and empiricist
speculation on the science of human
nature on acquisition of knowledge on
those parts of knowledge derived from
the original hand of Nature and so on
I have repeatedly emphasized that R and
E as I have discussed them
depart from some of the central ideas of
the tradition
for example the belief that the contents
of the Mind are open to introspection
furthermore
these leading ideas often interpenetrate
in the work of one person in complex
ways
and we are under no compulsion to adhere
strictly to one or the other framework
but I do think that by sharpening these
opposed conceptions and exploring them
in the light of Empirical research
we can move toward a solution to
problems that can now sensibly be posed
with regard to the nature and
acquisition of cognitive structures
and at the same time
we can gain much insight into the
reasons why earlier efforts have often
gone astray
this has been an audible Inc production
of
on language
chomsky's classic Works language and
responsibility and Reflections on
language
written by Noam Chomsky and mitsuhana
narrated by phager Al Casey